thank you
hey everyone first up a very big thanks
for actively tuning in to Overlake
oriented videos
talking about tech we bring you an
exciting tech savvy week with full-on
cutting-edge tutorials based on software
development starting from the
fundamentals of data structures and
algorithms to mastering the
state-of-the-art Frameworks and getting
involved into the latest and trending
projects for your portfolio so without
any further Ado let's get started with
our day one of the software development
Journey
so on day one we get to start with the
fundamentals of software development
where we get to master the data
structures the data structures act as
the foundation of any software program
it's important for the developers to
have a comfortable understanding of data
structures and learn The Knack of
implementing them in real time the sole
reason for which we have devised and
strategically organized all the critical
data structure tutorials along with the
real-time examples in the learning order
so how does algorithm work in real life
so we'll have a use case here on my
screen we have a lady and she is Shreya
Shreya wants to make some tea and for
that she's following some steps so the
first step is she'll take a pan and fill
it with water and place it on a gas stub
followed by that the second step is
she'll make sure that the water comes to
a nice boil and then she adds some tea
leaves and sugar
followed by step two we have step 3
where she'll allow the leaf to be fully
expanded and she'll add some milk after
that
next we have the step 4 where she will
wait for the tea to come for a good
decent boil
next we have step 5 where she'll turn
off the gas and she'll take the pan off
from the stove and the tea is ready to
get filtered and lastly we have the step
6 where she is all set with the teeth
so in computer science an algorithm is a
method or set of rules that we must be
following to perform some specific
calculations or other problem solving
operations
as a result an algorithm is a collection
of rules or instructions that govern how
a work needs to be conducted step by
step to achieve the desired results to
accomplish a task we first provide some
input and then follow a sequence of
steps to acquire the required outcome of
the input so that is the fundamental
definition of an algorithm and we also
had a use case and now we will move
ahead and understand the characteristics
of algorithms
so basically we have six characteristics
of algorithm so the first one is it
should be clear and unambiguous the
second one is that it has to be well
defined inputs and the third one is that
it has to be having well-defined outputs
as well the fourth property of an
algorithm is its feasibility followed by
that finiteness and finally we have
language Independence
now we will look into each one of the
characteristics in detail so first we
have clear and unambiguous so this
statement is the one which states that
the algorithm should be straightforward
simple and easily readable each one of
its steps should be distinct in every
way and Lead it to a single conclusion
so the next one is it should be having
well-defined inputs so this means that
an algorithm should indicate what output
can be expected as well as the input
should be properly well defined now we
have the third one similarly we should
also have well-defined outputs so the
well-defined output characteristics of
an algorithm means that the algorithm
must clearly indicate what output can be
expected as well as the output should
also be well defined followed by the
third characteristic we have the fourth
characteristic that is the finiteness of
algorithm so the finiteness of algorithm
says that the algorithm must be finite
and it must not result in in finite
Loops or similar situations so followed
by the fourth one we have the fifth
characteristic that defines about the
feasibility of an algorithm
so feasibility of an algorithm states
that the algorithm must be really simple
generic and practical it must be able to
be executed with resources available
now the last characteristic of the
algorithm is being independent of the
language
so it means that the algorithm should be
defined in such a way that it is
completely independent of the language
it must be simple instructions that can
be implemented using any programming
language
so these were the six major
characteristics of algorithm now let's
move ahead and understand how to write
an algorithm writing an algorithm does
not have any hard and fast rules
next algorithms are never created to
support a specific programming language
as we all know algorithms should be
capable enough to support the
conditional statements such as if if as
switch Etc an algorithm should be
capable enough to execute some of the
conditional statements such as if if
else switch Etc and also it must be
capable to execute the iterative
statements such as for Loop while loop
blue while loop Etc
we usually create algorithms in a
step-by-step manner however this isn't
always the case
after the problem domain has been well
defined algorithm writing is a procedure
that is carried out
we build an algorithm to find a solution
to a problem a problem can be resolved
in a variety of ways let's look at an
example of how to write an algorithm
consider the following scenario we need
to create an algorithm to determine the
largest number among the three given
numbers X Y and Z as a result the
initial solution to the problem can be
written in this manner so we begin with
reading all the three numbers and in the
second step we will have a condition
that says if x is greater than y we will
proceed to step 4 else we will proceed
to step 5. next in Step 4 we establish a
condition that if x a is greater than Z
then X is the largest of the three
numbers otherwise Z is the largest if Y
is greater than z z will be the greatest
number otherwise y will be the largest
number amongst all the three in step 5.
and the procedure will be terminated
let's have a look at what the next
solution has to offer in this algorithm
We Begin by reading all the three
variables then compare all the three
numbers in the third step to determine
the largest number which is if x is
greater than y then there is another if
else statement that states that if x is
greater than y then X is largest
otherwise Z is the largest
then this if else statement which says
that if Y is greater than Z then Y is
greater otherwise Z is the greatest of
the three numbers so this is how we have
multiple solutions to the same problem
so after discussing these Solutions we
will move ahead and understand algorithm
analysis
the algorithm may be studied in two
levels first before it is made and then
after it is created the two analysis of
an algorithm are as follows the first
one is priori analysis and the second
one is the post analysis so first we
will talk about the priori analysis
priori analysis refers to the
theoretical analysis of an algorithm
performed before its implementation
before implementing the algorithm other
parameters such as processor speed might
be considered which does not affect the
implementation component next we will
talk about post analysis a practical
analysis of an algorithm is called as
posterior analysis and it utilizes any
computer language to build the algorithm
the purpose of this analysis is to
determine how much time and space the
algorithm takes to operate now after
being understood the algorithm analysis
we will be able to comprehend the
algorithm complexity two methods can be
used to assess the algorithm complexity
the first one is time complexity which
states that the amount of time required
to finish an algorithm's execution is
known as its time complexity
followed by time complexity the other
one is the space complexity which is
calculated by the quantity of space
required to solve a problem and produce
an output of space complexity of an
algorithm
let's take a closer look at these
complexities now we will begin with time
complexity of an algorithm the Big O
notation is used to express an
algorithm's time complexity the
asymptomatic notation is used to depict
temporarily complexity of Big O notation
the time complexity is mainly determined
by counting the number of steps required
to complete the task
let's take a look at an example to
understand this time complexity in a
much better way if we want to find out
the multiplication of n numbers we can
do it by executing a loop from 1 to n
then calculating multiplication when the
loop ends then multiplication holds the
N numbers multiplication and last we
return the calculated multiplication the
loop statements time complexity will be
at least n and when the number of n
increases the time complexity will also
increase while the code's complexity
that is returns multiplication will
remain constant because its value is
unaffected by the value of N and it will
obtain the result in every single step
next we will discuss about space
complexity which is expressed with Big O
notation just as time complexity
these four items are stored in space
complexity it initially says program
instructions then stores constant values
then stores variable values and finally
it keeps track of function cells jumping
statements and so on the sum of
auxiliary space and input size is used
to calculate space complexity the extra
space or temporary space used by an
algorithm is referred to an auxiliary
space after learning about algorithm
complexity we will look at some of the
algorithms pros and cons so let's start
with the advantages of algorithms
firstly algorithms are easy to
understand next algorithms are
step-by-step representation of a
solution and lastly the problem is
broken down into smaller bits or steps
in an algorithm making it easier for the
programmer now an algorithm also have
various drawbacks one of which being it
takes long time to write hence it is
time consuming second cone of the
algorithm is algorithms make it harder
to demonstrate branching and looping
statements so followed by the advantages
and disadvantages of algorithms we now
enter into the final segment where we
discuss the differences between
algorithms and programming so the first
difference is that an algorithm is a
type of programming on the other hand a
program has more directly associated
with the computer performing one or more
tasks but an algorithm is more fun
notation a technique for solving a
problem
now let us discuss the second difference
an algorithm can be decoded or run by a
human whereas the program has only run
or decoded by a set of compilers of the
computer
now the third difference basically an
algorithm is a design of the solution to
the problem
here we can only analyze the solution
but we can never run it but whereas on
the other hand programming is completely
a different ball game here you can
directly Implement a certain phase or an
entire program and test the programs and
get an output so the fourth and the last
difference between an algorithm and
programming is an algorithm is written
using natural human vocabulary whereas
programs are written using any
programming language such as C C plus
plus Java python Etc now let's get
started with our first concept that is
what are data structures data is an
information that has been translated
into a form that is efficient to
movement or processing in Computing as
it relates to today's computers and
transmission media data is an
information that has been converted into
binary digital form the term raw data
refers to the data in its most basic
digital format after defining data let's
look at what data structure entails a
data structure is a data organization
management and storage format in
computer science that allows for
efficient access and modification or a
data structure is an algebraic structure
about data that contains a collection of
data values their relationships and
their functions or operations that can
be applied to the data
we will now understand why exactly we
need data structures now that we have
already defined what is a data structure
so let us have a look at some of the
data structure characteristics the first
one is each data structure allows data
to be stored differently following that
the data structure allows for more
efficient data search and retrieval then
specific data structures are chosen to
solve specific problems last but not the
least it enables the management of large
amounts of data such as last databases
and indexing services such as hash
tables let us now look at some real
world examples of data structures first
in the foremost we have the dictionary
assume that we are looking for the word
simply learn in the dictionary
and we know what begins with the letter
s so we can search for this word
beginning with the letter S and then
this is an example of array data
structure as a result this dictionary
can also function like an array data
structure following by that we have a
music player example if you have a
playlist with three songs the second
song will play after the first and the
third will play after the second so
these will be played without any
Interruption because all these three
songs are linked with each other using
linked list type of data structure so
followed by linked list the next example
we have is the data structures
the stack of books analogy is a perfect
example of the real-time working of the
Stacked data structure subsequent to
that assume there is a line of people at
a ticket window and the person who comes
first gets the ticket
this particular movie window queue is an
example for the real-time implementation
of Q data structure
last but not the least Google Maps
Google Map is the graph data structure
in which all the cities and states are
connected if we want to go from one
place to another there may be many ways
to do so so we can use some algorithms
to find the shortest path
as a result the Google Map is a perfect
example for the graph data structure
working analogy
following that we will look at some
different types of data structures in
this tutorial
so the first type is the linear data
structure
the elements in the linear data
structure are arranged subsequently one
after the other they are simple to
implement because the elements are
arranged in specific order
followed by the first type the second
type is the non-linear data structure
which we will be discussing a bit later
so in linear data structures we have
four different types the first one is
the array data structure memory elements
are arranged in a continuous order in
Aries and Aries elements are of scene
type the software program also
determines the type of elements that can
be stored in arrays so followed by
arrays we have linked list linked lists
are completely similar to data
structures data elements in linked list
data structure are linked together by a
series of nodes furthermore each node
contains the data items as well as the
address to the next node
the third data structure is the stack
data structure elements in a stacked
data structure are stored using lifo
principle in other words the last
element stored in the stack is removed
first in stack operations can only be
performed in one end namely the top and
the last data structure is the queue
data structure
unlike stack queue data structure
operates in the fifo principle which
states that the first element stored in
the queue is removed first in a queue
insertion and deletion are carried out
from opposite ends now we will discuss
the second type of data structures which
are the non-linear data structures the
non-linear data structure is the second
type of data structure non-linear data
structures do not have elements in any
order as opposite to the linear data
structures instead they are arranged in
hierarchical order with one element
connected to one or more others
so the first one in the non-linear data
structures is the three data structure a
tree data structure is built using nodes
and edges each element in the free data
structure is called as node or vertex
each Vertex or node is connected to the
other nodes or other vertices using
edges and the second one in the list is
the graft data structure a graph data
structure is completely like a tree data
structure it also has the vertices and
edges each vertex in a graph data
structure is connected using edges the
only difference between a tree and graph
is that entry you can have n number of
vertices but in graph you will have only
two vertices
after discussing the graph data
structure we will move ahead into the
last segment of this tutorial that is
importance of data structures so the
first one data structures are widely
used in almost every aspect of computer
science both for simple and complex
computations
next data structures are used in all
areas of computer science including
artificial intelligence Graphics Big
Data operating systems and much more
after that the data structures are an
essential component of many computer
algorithms because they allow
programmers to manage data efficiently
lastly a proper data structure of
selection can improve the efficiency of
a computer program or algorithm
there are various programming languages
that you can learn to help your code
data structures
we will discuss C language
C plus plus
Python and Java
let's discuss them in detail
first up C language
C is a general purpose structure
programming language
C language can be used to develop
programs like operating systems
compilers databases and so on
C language has a vast library that
contains numerous built-in functions
next up C plus plus language
C plus plus is also a general purpose
programming language
C plus plus supports seven styles of
programming
like functional structural and object
oriented programming
is also used in creating operating
systems browsers and Games
Etc
next up Python programming
python is the most significant
programming language because the syntax
of a Python Programming can be easy to
understand to every learner's level
and this programming language is also
loaded with the full of libraries that
helps in implementing scientific
computing
working and deployment of python are
supportive and Easy in any environment
finally Java programming language
in this modern era Java is the best
language to choose
nearly thousands of applications
softwares and development tools are
built using the Java programming
language
the technology is primarily used in
creating websites such as YouTube Google
Amazon Flipkart and many more
moving forward now that you have a
better understanding of which
programming languages you would like to
code with let's understand what are the
prerequisites you need to learn to get
started with the data structures and
algorithms
first up basic syntax
before you start writing any code you
need to have basic syntax on your tips
or you may run into various errors
next up
data types
you want to make your code perform
various operations and you would need to
understand data types
and their syntax
next up operators variables and
functions
these are the elements that makes a code
functional or operational
the data types are essential in
declaring them
next up conditional statements or Loops
let's say if we want to print only a
specific part of the information when
certain conditions are met then we can
write conditional statements if else if
we were going to print a lot of elements
like all natural numbers from 1 to 100
with a bit of code then we can write
Some Loops like for Loop or while loop
then we will discuss object oriented
programming
object oriented programming or oops is
built around objects which are data
structures that contains both data and
the code
next up we will discuss data structures
we will start with arrays linked list
stack
queues
trees
graphs and heaps
now let's have a closer look at them
first up arrays
an array is collection of elements
stored in consecutive memories
an array is a most basic data structures
the majority of data structure and
algorithms can be implemented with the
help of arrays
next up is linked list
a linked list is a linear data
structures made of nodes
these nodes are made up of two parts
data and the address to the next node
linked lists are easier to work with and
they are faster at insertion and
deletion
next up stacks
stack is a linear data structure that
follows a particular order from which
the operations are performed we can
perform insertion and deletion only from
the top
this is also why sticks are called
last in first off or lifo based data
structures
in stack insertion is referred to as
push operation and deletion as Pop
operation
next up queues
cues is also an abstract data structures
but unlike Stakes a queue is open at
both its end one end is used for
insertion
also referred to as enqueue and the
other is used for deletion also known as
DQ
this is why the queue is regarded as
first and first out or fifo based data
structure
following trees
a tree is a hierarchical data structures
made up of nodes the first node of the
tree or the node which has no parents is
called root mode else all of the other
nodes can have a maximum of one parent
and can have multiple childrens
each node contains some data and links
to its childrens
next up graph
a graph is non-linear data structure
consists of nodes and edges
the nodes are sometimes also referred to
be as vertices
and the edges are lines and arcs that
connects any of the two nodes
graphs are often used to represent
Networks
finally Heap
a heap is a special case of trees
peep is a complete binary that is it can
have maximum of two children and all
level except for the last level should
be filled
a he is of two types Maxi and minhip
when every node has a value greater than
its parent then the Heap is called Max
Heap
and when every node in a he has less
value than its parent then that t is
called minhip
now that you have a firmed grasp of
basic coding and data structures we will
discuss some algorithms
we will first discuss searching and
sorting
that we will discuss divide and conquer
then greedy algorithm
dynamic programming and backtrack
let's discuss them in detail
first up searching
searching algorithms are intended to
search and retrieve an element from any
data structure in which it is true
next
sorting algorithm is used to rearrange
the elements of an array a list based on
the comparison operator on the element
efficient sorting is critical for
enhancing the efficiency of other
algorithm that needs input to be sorted
list
next up divide and conquer
this algorithm requires to divide the
whole problem into sub problems and
solve them and then combine them back to
get a complete solution
some algorithms follow this approach
like quick sort merge sort and streng
sense algorithm
divide and conquer requires that there
must be more than two sub problems
next is greedy approach
the greedy algorithm aims to build up a
solution by selecting the most
beneficials option
greedy is best suited to problems when
picking the locally optimal also leads
to a global solution
the greedy can also be used to solve
Huffman coding job sequencing and
knapsack problems
next up dynamic programming
a dynamic programming technique that
produces smaller sub problems and then
uses the sub problem solutions to solve
the more significant problem
dynamic programming is nothing but
optimization of recursion problems
simple optimization can change the time
complexity from exponential to
polynomial
next up backtracking
backtracking is an algorithmic approach
to recursively solving problems by
attempting to develop a solution
progressively
one piece at a time
then discarding any solution that do not
fulfill the problems criteria at any
point in time
backtracking is also used to solve
problems like end Queens Sudoku
hamiltonian Cycles Etc
we have now discussed both data
structures and algorithms now let's have
a look at top coding contests or
platforms to hone your skills
we will start with hackering
then code beta
Geeks coding challenge code jam and at
last code chef
let's discuss them in detail
first up hacker rank
hacker rank is a technology hiring
platform that is standard for assessing
developer skills
rank organizes various contexts like
rank hack Fest and hack the interview
next up code beta
code beta is coding platform where one
can compete against pupils from all over
the globe for the world's best coder
title
Tata consultancy services or TCS
organizes core beta winners usually win
prizes like cash prizes or free vouchers
it also opens up a door for career
opportunities for its learners
next up geek coding challenge
key coding challenge is a three-day
event organized by Geeks for geeks
in GCC Learners can participate and
challenge themselves in solving coding
problems to win prizes
next up code Jam
code Jam is a Google hosted and managed
International programming competition
the competition consists of collection
of algorithmic tasks that must be
completed within a specific time limit
at last code chef
code Chef is a website that aims to
assist programmers in succeeding in
algorithms computer programming and
programming competitions
code Chef often organizes various
contacts like cook-offs and lunchtime
we have now discussed various coding
platforms or competitions to hone your
skills
first up let's say if you can't solve a
problem in under an hour
you should put it aside for the time
being and move on you can always return
to it at a later time
next up even if you answer the question
correctly I recommend that you read the
discussion and look at other Solutions
you could come up with a better way to
answer that question
finally if you are having trouble
understanding a solution then I
recommend you to dry run of the code
introduction to time complexity
the time complexity of an algorithm is
the amount of time it takes to run as a
function of the length of that input
the length of the input determines how
many operations the algorithm will do
it will provide the information about
the variance increase or decrease in
execution time as the number of
operations in an algorithm increases or
decreases
next up types of time complexity
we will start with the constant time
complexity then we will discuss linear
code
logarithmic quadratic time complexity
now let's have a look at them
in the detail
first
constant time complexity
when an algorithm is not reliant on the
input size n it is said to have constant
time of order bigger of 1.
the runtime will always be the same
regardless of the input
as you can see in the code every line
has the runtime of 1.
and they are all independent of any
input size so the runtime is always
constant
next up linear time complexity
when an algorithm's running time
increases linearly with the length of
end input it is said to have linear time
complexity
when a function checks all the values in
an input data set it is said to have the
time complexity of order of bigger of n
as you can see in the code the loop
depends on the size n so the time
complexity will rows up to n
next up logarithmic time complexity
when an algorithm lowers the input data
in each step then it is said to have the
logarithmic time complexity
binary trees or binary search functions
are some of the algorithms with
logarithmic time complexity
as you can see in this code by finding
out the mid in every iteration the run
time will decrease every step making it
approximately logarithmic runtime
next up quadratic time complexity
when the execution time of algorithm
Rises non-linearly up to n square with
the length of the input it is said to
have quadratic time complexity
in general net nested Loops falls into
the quadratic time complexity order
where one Loop takes bigger of N and if
the function contains the loop inside
the loop then it multiplies
as you can see in this code because of
the nested Loops the time complexity
Rose to n Square
now that you have the firm grasp of time
complexity and its type we will discuss
essential steps to evaluate the time
complexity
to understand this we will take an
example of Fibonacci number
this code prints the Fibonacci numbers
till n
we will divide this code into three
parts isolating all the loops that play
a significant role in altering the time
complexity
let's look at the first part
it consists of some independent
statement which gave
constant runtime for each statement
next let's move in on to our next part
that is for Loop
since this Loop runs n times this will
give linear time complexity on n
next up the third part which also has
the constant time complexity
now let's take a total of runtime
which comes out to be n Plus 5. we will
then discard the constant part to find
the time complexity which does not
affect the overall time complexity now
we will have the final time complexity
of Big O of n
we have now discussed time complexity
and how to evaluate it
now let's have a look at the time
complexity of various algorithm
we will look at the time complexity of
insertion sort merge sort quick sort
bubble sort
and some searching algorithms like
linear search and binary search
let's look at them in the detail
first up insertion sort
as you can see in this code we are using
nested loops so in worst case its
complexity comes out to be n Square now
in the best case scenario the complexity
will be linear time complexity
next up merge sort
in this case whether it is the worst
case or the best case it will always
remain n log n as every statement in
this code will run the same amount so no
matter what its time complexity will
remain the same
next up quick sort
the time complexity of quick sort in the
best case is n Logan
and and in the worst case it is
elsewhere
next up bubble sort
as you can see in this code we are using
nested Loops so in the worst case its
complexity comes out to be n Square
now in the best case scenario the time
complexity will become the linear time
complexity that is n
and after that we will discuss some of
the searching algorithms first up linear
search
in the best case scenario if the
statement to be searched is that the
first position then the time complexity
will come out to be constant whereas in
the worst case the time complexity will
come out to be n
finally binary search
in the best case scenario if the element
is to be searched is at the mid then the
time complexity will come out to be the
constant whereas in the first case
scenario the time complexity will come
out to be bigger of login
we have now discussed the time
complexity and how to evaluate
and the time complexity of various
algorithm now let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up the execution time increases
with the types of operations we make
using the inputs
next up the lesser the time complexity
the faster is the execution
finally if a code is of hundreds of
lines then it takes at all on the PCS
processor so it is essential to check
and reduce the time complexity as much
as we can
let's get started with what are Pointers
a pointer is a variable that points to
an address of another variable it is
declared using a star symbol also called
asterisk
and then we allocate a memory of a
variable to it we can access a
variable's address using the Ampersand
symbol in the same manner as the pointer
declaration let's write a code
we will declare a variable a is equals 5
and a pointer PTR
then we will assign this variable is
value to pointer PTR
now let's write a print statement to
directly access the variables value
using variable name
foreign
let's write another print statement to
print the value of a using pointer
foreign
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
accessed variables value using both
variable name and pointers
let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss different types of
pointers
first up null pointer
void pointer
wild pointer
and dangling pointer
let's discuss these in details
first up null pointer it is a kind of
pointer that points to a null memory as
you can see in the figure here is a
pointer which is pointing to a null
memory
to get a better understanding let's try
a simple program in the code editor
let's write a code first we will declare
a pointer where
then we will assign its value to null
now let's try to print the statement
let's execute this
as you can see since this pointer points
to a null or nothing that's why it
doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides next void
pointer when a pointer is created with
data type void then this pointer is
called void pointer
if we want to print the variables value
then we have to Typecast this pointer to
avoid any error for better understanding
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple code first we will
declare an integer variable a is equals
to 5.
and avoid pointer PTR
now we will assign address of a to
pointer PTR
let's write a print statement to print
this pointer
let's run this program
as you can see we are getting an error
that's because we can't print a void
variable
in this we have to Typecast this
variable to integer let's do this
we can type cast a variable like this
now let's print this
as you can see we can print it now
let's get back to our slides
next while pointer when we create a
pointer but don't initialize it by
assigning any memory to it then this
kind of pointer is called while pointer
these pointers can be very tricky they
can even cause a program failure or a
segmentation fault
let's get back to the curator and try it
with a simple code
first let's declare a pointer PTR
but they will not assign it with any
address
let's write a print statement to print
it this time we will directly print it
let's execute this
as you can see we are not getting any
results because there is no value
assigned to it sometimes it may even
show segmentation error
let's get back to our slides
next dangling pointer
let's Suppose there is a pointer P which
is pointing at a variable now if we
delocate this memory using a free
function
then this pointer will point at a free
space or a non-existing memory then this
pointer will become a dangling pointer
to get a better understanding of this
pointer let's try it with a simple code
let's declare a pointer PTR
here we will dynamically allocate memory
using a Matlock function
to do this we will put int star in a
bracket
then
lock function
and in another bracket we will put
memory size to be allocated
now let's declare a variable a
and assign its address to the pointer
now to make it a dangling pointer we
have to de-allocate the memory of this
pointer
we will use free function for that
now let's write a print statement to
print this pointer
let's execute it
as you can see since we have deallocated
its memory that's why it is pointing to
nothing hence it doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides
till now we have discussed pointers ways
to access variables and types of
pointers now let's talk about use cases
of pointers we will talk about Point
arithmetics pointer to pointer array of
pointers call by value and call by
reference now let's dive right into it
let's talk about Pointer arithmetics we
can use four arithmetic operations on
pointers
increment decrement addition or
subtraction of an integer from a pointer
since pointer operates on addresses it
only makes sense if we apply pointer
arithmetics on sequential data
structures like arrays or strings let's
discuss them in detail
first up increment
if we apply this operator on a pointer
then it will shift this Pointer's
address to its sequential successor as
you can see in the figure as we
increment the Pointer's value we shift
to the next index of the array
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple program
let's declare an array of size 3.
skip them some value
foreign
ER
and assign it to the arrays first
element
now let's write a for Loop to Traverse
this array
in this for Loop we will increment a
Pointer's value
and print this Pointer's value to
Traverse this array
let's try and execute this product
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array
let's get back to our slides
next decrement
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will shift this Pointer's address to
its sequential predecessor as you can
see in the figure as we decrement this
pointer we also shift to arrays previous
index
let's get back to the coordinator and
try to implement it let's declare an
array of size 3.
and assign it some values
now let's declare a pointer
and assign arrays last elements address
to it
now let's write a for Loop
to Traverse this array
in this for Loop we will decrement the
Pointer's value
also we will keep printing this
Pointer's value to travel this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from the back
let's get back to our slides
next the addition of an integer to a
pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will leave forward accordingly if the
integer is 2 and our pointer points at
the first element then the pointer will
sequentially skip one element and shift
to the next element
let's implement it in the code editor
let's declare an array of size 7.
and assign them some value
then declare a pointer
and assign it to the arrays first
element
foreign
integer n to add in the pointer
now let's write a for Loop to Traverse
this array
in this for Loop we will increment the
Pointer's value with integer n
and we will keep printing the pointer
ptr's value
let's execute this code
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array skipping one element at a
time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
next subtraction of an integer from a
pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
then accordingly it will leap backward
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the last element then the
pointer will skip one element and shift
to the previous element
let's try and implement it in the code
editor first let's declare an array of
size 7.
and assign it some values
then declare a pointer PTR
and assign it to the arrays last element
now let's take an integer and to
subtract from the pointer
now let's write a for Loop to Traverse
this array
in this for Loop we will decrement the
Pointer's value with integer n
also we will write an print statement to
print this ptr's value
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traveled this
complete array from back skipping one
element at a time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
let's talk about presidents of these
operators
operator asterisk and one percent have
the same priority as the unary operator
increment and decrement
these operators are evaluated from right
to left
let's understand this concept with an
example suppose if a pointer P points to
a variable X then we can swap x with
pointer p in that expression in the
first row we have y is equal to X Plus 1
which means we are storing an
incremented value of x in y similarly if
we replace x with a pointer P we can
store incremented value of pointer in y
in Row 2 and Row 3 we are incrementing X
and storing incremented value in X
itself
we can do this with pointers as well in
Row 4 we are attempting to execute
pre-increment with a pointer p
in Row 5 we are attempting to execute
post increment with pointer p here we
have to put star p in braces because
these operators are evaluated from right
to left so to give more priority to
pointer P we have to use braces as they
have highest priority
let's talk about another use case
pointer to pointer
basically in this situation a pointer
will point at a variable via another
pointer we declare it with two extra six
symbols let's discuss it with an example
suppose a pointer 1 points to a variable
and another pointer 2 points to that
pointer one this way pointer 2 will
indirectly be pointing to the variable
let's go to the code editor and try
implementing it
first we will declare a variable where
foreign
and a pointer to this pointer ptr2
then we will assign this variable
where's address to ptr1
and
ptr1's address to ptr2
now we will write a print statement to
print variable VAR ptr1 and ptr2
foreign
and execute this program
as you can see
ptr1 and ptr2 shows variable Vats value
as ptr2 is pointing to ptr1 and ptr1 is
pointing to that variable so indirectly
PTR 2 points to the variable where
thus it prints the variables value
let's get back to our slides
let's discuss the array of pointers
as the name suggests it is an array that
has all its elements as pointers these
pointers can be pointing at another
array it is declared as an array with a
specific symbol
let's discuss it with the program first
we will declare an array a of size 3.
then we will declare
a pointer array PTR of size 3.
now we will write a for Loop to assign
as elements address to ptr's element
foreign
Loop to Traverse PTR and print its
element
foreign
let's try and execute this program
as you can see it prints the value of
array is elements because error ptr's
elements are pointing to array as
elements let's get back to our slides
next call by value
we don't use pointers in this concept
but it is very important to understand
this concept to get better understanding
of the next topic call by reference
value we call a function and directly
pass the variables value as parameters
in this situation a copy of those
variable is created and get passed into
a function as parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
not affect actual variables rather these
copies will get deleted as soon as the
function body ends let's try
implementing it in the code editor
let's write a code
first we will declare a variable x
equals to 100
then we will write a function call to
function func with argument X
next we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happened due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
we will take a void function
with argument as X
in this first we will set x equals to
and then we will write a print statement
to print this value
let's try and execute this program
as you can see here when we get back to
the main block from function its value
again reverted back to 10. because in
call by value program we only pass
variables copy into the function not the
actual variables
let's get back to our slides
next call by reference
in this if we call a function but this
time we pass the variables address as
parameters then in this situation actual
variables will get passed into the
function as parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
modify the actual variables even outside
the function scope
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
first we will declare a variable and x
equals to 100
next we will write a function call for
function func with argument as address
of x
foreign
statement to check if any changes happen
due to the function
foreign
definition for this function
it will be a void function
with argument as pointer X
in this we will first set x equals to
200.
then we will write a print statement to
print this value of x
now let's try and execute this program
foreign
as you can see this time variable access
value didn't revert 200 that's because
in call by reference we'll pass actual
variables address to functions so it
will modify them as well
let's get back to our slides
during the course of this video we have
learned a lot about pointers let's
discuss some advantages of the pointers
first up pointers are useful to access a
memory location pointers are also an
effective way to access the array
elements
pointers are used for the dynamic memory
allocation and its distribution
pointers are also used to build complex
data structures like linked list graph
tree stack queue Etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well first up pointers are difficult
to understand so a programmer needs to
be careful while handling them
they might raise some errors like
segmentation error or access some
unrequired memory and course program
failure if a pointer is pointing to an
incorrect value then it might corrupt
memory
pointers may also cause memory leakage
also pointers are slower than variables
so to understand this let's go through a
simple concept
let us imagine that we have some data
and the data is related to students
right so if we wanted to store the marks
of individual students then we had to
declare a variable for each of the
student
so you can see we have student 1 student
2 student 3 4 and 5 and their individual
scores so the score 1 is assigned to
student 1 and so on with student 5 being
assigned to score 5.
so in the real time this might be a
little clumsy we have here just five
students so that is okay but what if we
had 500 students or 5000 students right
that might be an issue there we have to
create some 500 or 5000 variables and it
would be a little tough to handle that
right even if we wanted to apply some
operations collectively on all the
variables that might be a little tedious
so what if we had one variable which
could store all the five students or 500
students or 5 000 students all together
and make it really easy for us to apply
some operations collectively on all the
students right this sounds a little bit
logical so similarly we do have a data
structure which can do that which can
collectively store all the data elements
in it as a single variable and it will
also help us to apply the operations
which are logical or mathematical on all
the variables and their values together
as a whole so that is the purpose why we
had created Aries that is the purpose
why we needed Aries
so far we have understood what was the
necessity for Aries now we will
understand what exactly are Aries
so basically an array is a linear data
structure that stores the elements in a
sequential manner one after the other
and when you declare an array the
variables will be stored one besides the
other that is adjacent to each other in
a sequential order now let us understand
how the array is represented by the
compiler
now the next part that is the memory
representation of Aries
now let us imagine that we have declared
an array which stores character type
data and another important point to
remember about R is when you declare an
array it stores only a single data type
typed elements only for example here we
have declared a character type array
right so we cannot store integer type
data or flow type data in it we only
have to save character type array or
character type elements in this
particular array
so now let's imagine that we have
created an array which is of character
data type and these are the elements
which are a r r a y now how does the
compiler represent it in the form of
memory
so when you create an array these are
found that is the index values and the
address so basically compiler will
select a block of memory and it has
addresses to that block and it can be
anything right here we have 11 12 13 14
and 15. and in real time it might be a
thousand one thousand two thousand three
thousand four thousand five the main
motto is assign a sequential block of
memory and this is the array and the
elements are a r r a y and this
particular one which is the last one is
the index of the array that is the
position of the array for users using
this index you can access the elements
in the array more on that in the
accessing part so let us imagine that we
wanted to access the element R so how to
access it we might not know the address
right in that instance we will use the
index this is for our reference so we
will tell I want the element from array
index number 2 and then we'll have the
ARR R element so in the Practical form
this is how we use the index
now let's continue with the lower bound
and the upper bound so the first initial
location is called as the lower bound
and at the last or the max value of the
array is called as the upper bound now
let's jump into the next topic where we
will understand the different types of
arrays
so these are the different types of
one dimensional Aries and
multi-dimensional arrays
in multi-dimensional arrays we have two
more types that is two dimensional
arrays and three dimensional arrays
so how are arrays different from each
other
right so the first one will deal with
the first one that is the one
dimensional array now how is an array
declared as one dimensional for that we
need subscript so one dimensional array
requires only one subscript to specify
the number of elements in an array so
how is it actually represented so here
you can see an example right on my
screen
so here is how a one-dimensional array
looks like so here we have the data type
that is integer data type and marks is
the name of the array and this is the
size of the array and here the elements
will be stored and here it is the index
value of the array and remember the
index value of array always starts from
zero in the previous example that was
only form basic understanding so I just
started that with one in the practical
way the array index always starts from
0. so followed by the one-dimensional
array we will deal with the
multi-dimensional arrays in that we have
the following the first one is the two
dimensional array and the second one is
the three-dimensional array
in the multi-dimensional arrays we
require more than one subscript in the
previous example we had one dimensional
array so this subscript is just one that
is 10 columns
right so we just had one single row and
10 different columns but in the
multi-dimensional arrays we need
multiple rows and multiple columns right
so we need two subscripts for two
dimensional array and more than two
subscripts for three dimensional arrays
so first we have the two dimensional
arrays the 2D array is organized in the
form of a matrix which can be
represented as a collection of rows and
columns so here is the example as you
can see on my screen we have three
columns and three rows and we have two
subscripts that Define the number of
rows and the number of columns and the
elements in each and every row so the
one two three confines the first row
four five six confines the second row
and seven eight nine will be the third
row now similarly we have three
dimensional Aries a 3D array is a
collection of 2D arrays which consists
of three subscripts block size row size
and column size
so here we have an example for that
so we have three subscripts that is the
first one is block size the second one
is the row number and the third one is
column number
so this happens to be the first block
this happens to be the second block and
this is how a three-dimensional array
can be represented
now we have the next stage where we will
understand how to declare the Aries and
the syntax is right on my screen you
need to specify the data type of the
array which is integer of load or
character any selection which you make
followed by that you need to select an
array name for your array and inside
that you need to declare the array size
and sometimes you can also eliminate the
rsis if you wanted to you know have a
dynamic array
and here is an example for that
you have integer data type name of the
array is example and the array size is
6.
so the compiler will allocate continuous
memory block of 6 integer type blocks
so these are the few more methods to
initialize the array so here you can see
integer data type array name is a
element size S5 and we have five
elements the method two is remember I
have said you can eliminate the size of
the array right so here you can use this
way as well integer data type rename a
and no size here and you can directly
declare the elements
and number two third so here you have
the name of the array size of the array
and you are allocating the elements to
the individual memory locations this is
also another method to initialize array
and method for as using a volume you can
just initialize a for Loop and the I
value will be stored in the array
locations starting from 0.
now let us understand how to access the
elements in an array
so to access the elements in an array
you need to specify the name of the
array and memory block where you have
that element that you want to access so
here we have an example which is integer
data type name of the array is XYZ and
the element we wanted to access as five
so here we have an example that is
integer type array array name is XYZ and
it has the size 5. and now we wanted to
access the first element in an array
that can be done using the first index
that is x y z of 0 index that is the
first element and accessing the second
element and so on x y z of 1 will be the
second element x y z of 2 3 4 will be
the third and fourth and fifth elements
now let us understand some basic
operations that can be performed on the
array elements
so the following are the operations that
can be performed on the array elements
that is the traversal insertion deletion
searching and sorting
now let us get into practical mode and
try to execute some examples based on
traversal of the array insertion of an
element into the array deletion of an
element from an array searching for an
element in an array and sorting the
complete array so at first we'll carry
out the traversal operation so here we
have an array that is a of five and the
elements are 1 2 3 4 and 5. now we are
going to use a for Loop to Traverse
through this array and print all the
elements sequentially now let us execute
this code and see the output
so as you can see the code got
successfully executed and the elements
that as one two three four and five from
the array a are printed sequentially now
moving ahead we'll try to execute some
examples based on insertion of element
into the array so on my screen you can
see an example for inserting an element
into the array at the starting position
of the array now let us try to execute
this code and see the output
don't worry about the codes these code
documents will be attached in the
description box below and you will be
able to have an access to it and run
these codes in your personal laptop and
get a better learning experience
now you can see the code got
successfully executed and now it is
asking for the size of the array let's
declare it as 5. and now let's enter the
elements into the array
now it is asking for the element to be
added at the beginning of the array now
we have 2 3 4 5 and 6 existing in the
array let's add the first element 1 and
there you go the resultant array is 1 2
3 4 5 and 6. the element which we added
at the ending which is one is supposed
to be in the first or the beginning part
of the array which is here at at the
first index location as plant now let's
get started with another example on the
insertion now let's try to insert an
element at any given location as per the
user's choice
so as you can see we have a program on
my screen and running this program must
help us to insert an element into any
given location of the array
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the output
so there you go enter the elements into
the array let's enter 1 3
let's try to run this program and see
the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now the output
is asking for us to tell it the number
of elements in an array now let's say
four elements
so now let's enter the four elements
one
three
four five and six
okay
so the four elements which is one three
four five are been inserted now it is
asking for the location where you want
to insert the element now let us insert
it in this second location
now let us set the value as 2 and there
you go the resultant array is one two
three four and five and the element
which is 2 was supposed to be added in
the second location and it has been
successfully added now let's try to
execute another example based on
insertion where you will try to insert
the element in the last position
now this program on my screen will help
us to add an element at the end of the
array let's quickly run this program
now it is asking for us to enter the
five elements of the array let's enter
that
now it is asking to enter the element to
be inserted now let us enter the element
and this element should be added at the
endless location as discussed the
resultant array is one three five seven
nine and 11.
now let's continue with the deletion
operation
now the program on my screen is an
example for deleting an element from the
beginning position of an array now the
program got successfully executed and
it's asking for us to enter the size of
the array let's enter the size as 5.
and now let's enter the elements of the
array that is 1
.
2 3 4 and 5.
now the element from the first location
that is 1 has been deleted and the
resultant array is 2 3 4 and 5. now the
code on my screen will help you to
eliminate the element from the ending
location of an array now let's try to
quickly run this program and say there
so you can see that the program is
successfully run and it is asking for us
to enter the size of the array let's
enter 4. now let's enter the elements of
the array that is 1 2 3 and 4. now after
eliminating the last element from the
array that is 4 we have the resultant
array that is 1 2 and 3.
now a little homework for you guys let's
try to execute an example for deleting
an element from any location of an array
this will be a homework now don't worry
try on your own and if you don't get
that you can refer to the comment
sections below where you have the code
document attached in the description box
and you can refer to it
now let's continue with the next
operation where we will search for a
given element in the array so you can
see that on my screen we have an example
which will help us to sort the elements
in an array let's quickly run this
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for the array size let's enter a
file and now let's enter the elements in
a random order
[Music]
now the resultant array should be sorted
so there you go the array after being
sort is it's 2 3 5 4921 so there you go
the array got sorted so now we have
finished our practical session let's
have a quick overview again
so traversal in an array is a process of
visiting each element once traversal can
be done by various means that is by
counting the array elements printing the
values sorted in the arrays and some of
all elements present in the array and
many more
so this is how we Traverse our array
from the first location to the last
location again the insertion operation
insertion in an array is a process of
including one or more elements in an
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index of an array which we executed for
all the three types of examples
now next we have the deletion operation
so deletion operation or deletion of an
element is a process of removing a
desired element and reorganizing the
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index so we have executed the example
for at the beginning and at the end and
the homework was at the given index
don't worry if you don't figure it out
you can always refer to the example
document which is mentioned in the
description box below
now the search operation searching is a
process of finding a given value in the
list of values and it decides whether
the search key is present in the array
or not and we have executed an example
on that
and again the sort operation where we
will sort the given array if the given
array is not in the default order or in
a given order that is ascending or
descending then we can sort the order of
the array by the user's Choice given it
is ascending order or descending order
now in the next section of the tutorial
we will discuss the advantages of using
Aries
so the first one is array stores
multiple elements of same data type with
same mean
next one elements in an array can be
accessed randomly using just the index
number array memory is predefined so
there is no extra memory loss
array Awards memory overflow and finally
2D arrays can represent the tabular form
of data in a very efficient way now let
us also have a look on some of the
disadvantages of using arrays
the first one the number of elements in
an array should be always predefined so
there is no chance that you can add some
extra element in the last moment
array is static in nature so its size
cannot be varied after declaration what
if considered that you wanted to store
10 student data in one array and you end
up having just seven students so the
remaining three is a waste right so you
are wasting memory there that's the
problem and insertion and deletion
operations in an array is quite
difficult as the aristos elements in a
continuous form
and finally allocating excess memory
band required may lead to memory wastage
now we have the final key takeaways of
the Aries
so we discussed why do we need arrays
then we discussed what our arrays
followed by that we discussed types of
arrays next we had Declaration of arrays
accessing elements from an array
initializing the arrays and basic
operations on iron that is the Practical
demo part and finally we have discussed
the advantages and disadvantages of
using an array
so we will see a brief definition of
arrays the array is a data structure
that stores elements of the same data
type in a sequential order
two dimensional arrays are considered as
an array of arrays
two-dimensional arrays represent the
information in the form of rows and
columns which is completely similar to a
tabular form of data following by the
definition and briefing of the two
dimensional arrays we will understand
the need for two dimensional Aries
so the main advantage of using a
two-dimensional array is the elements
can be represented in the form of a
matrix that is rows and columns
using two dimensional arrays we can
initialize access and print multiple
elements in The Matrix form by just
running one single code segment you can
see an example right on my screen here
this is an example of Mark's list
suppose a class has three subjects
namely English science and maths
we have four students and we wanted to
represent the data in the form of a
database so here the marks of the four
students can be represented using two
dimensional arrays
now we will see the syntax of a two
dimensional array so here the syntax
at first we need the data type the data
type can be integer character float
string Etc then we have the name for the
two-dimensional array and later we can
have two subscripts which represent two
Dimensions that is the rows and columns
the first subscript defines the number
of flows and the second subscript
defines the number of columns and note
that the column number can never be null
at the end we have a semicolon to
terminate the syntax
and here we have some examples of two
dimensional arrays so in the first
example we have the name of the two
dimensional array and we have
three rows and four columns
and followed by that we have another
example which is of character data type
and the name of the array is names and
we have 7 rows and 15 columns
next we will see how to visualize two
dimensional arrays
we read earlier that two dimensional
arrays are a collection of rows and
columns let's see an example of two
dimensional array we will consider an
array with 6 rows and four columns as
you can see on my screen we have integer
type array and the name of the array is
array and we have six rows and four
columns
the product of rows and columns will
give us the total number of elements
present in a two-dimensional array in
the current example we have six rows and
four columns and the product is 24 so we
must have 24 elements in this array
next we will see how to initialize two
dimensional arrays
so there are two ways to initialize a
two dimensional array so in the first
method we declare the elements in the
set of curly brackets
this array consists of three rows and
three columns
note that the index always starts from
zero here we have three rows it means
the row starts with 0 and ends with 2.
the same goes for the column but
sometimes this method might be a little
confusing so we have a better method the
advantage of this method is clarity
we can visualize all the elements with
better Clarity compared to the previous
method so the first three elements are 9
6 and 1. they are present in the first
row
and in the second row we have 144 70 and
50. they comprise the second row and
finally the third row in which the
elements are 10 12 and 78. so far we
have learned how to visualize and
initialize a two-dimensional array so we
have done it by using the index values
that is the row index and the column
index so the row index value was 3 and
the column index value was 3. for
accessing an element in the
two-dimensional array we need to pass
the name of the two dimensional array
followed by the row index value and the
column index value for example let us
assume that we wanted to access the
element nine for doing so we will pass
the name of the array followed by the
row index value and the column index
value as shown below that is end first 0
comma 0.
and an important Point here is indexing
always starts with zero we will now
start printing the two dimensional
arrays so to print a two-dimensional
array we will be using two nested for
loops
so to understand the process of printing
the two-dimensional array let's get back
to the Practical mode and we will work
on a code
so on my screen you can see an example
for two-dimensional array so here we
have declared an array with the name
first and we have three rows and three
columns and inside that the first row of
elements is 961 and the second row of
elements is 144 70 and 50 and the third
row of elements is 10 12 and 78.
followed by that we have two counter
variables which are I and G so we are
using the first counter variable I in
the order for Loop and the second
counter variable J in the second in the
fall
and inside the inner follow we have a
print statement which is used to print
the elements in the array
now
let us try to execute this code and see
the output
so you can see the code got successfully
compiled and we have our elements here
which is 961 144 70 50 10 12 and 78. now
let us understand the logic so here we
have declined the counter variable as 0
and the condition is I should be less
than 3 which is true so the control will
enter into the second in the for Loop
here we have J is equals to 0 and J
should be less than 3 which is true so
here the condition or the statement
is valid and it will print the first
element 9.
followed by that J will be incremented
again J is now equals to 1 and J is less
than 3 so again we'll print the second
element 6.
again J value will be incremented to 2
so 2 is less than 3 then we will print
the third element that is 1. now when
you increment the value of J from 2 to 3
the condition will fail because 3 cannot
be less than 3. so the control will
enter into the outer for Loop here we
have I value is equals to 0 which will
be incremented to 1. so 1 is less than 3
again the control will enter the inner
for Loop here again we will check for J
is equals to 0 which is true so we will
print the second row of elements that is
144 70 50 in the same way how we printed
the first row right so J will be equals
to 0 so then we'll print the first
element so J will be incremented to 1
and 1 is less than 3 then we will print
the second element that is 70 and again
J will be incremented to 2
and 2 is less than 3 so we will print
the third element that is 50 in the
second row and again J will be
incremented to 3 now the compilation of
the condition will result in false so it
will exit the second follow point but it
will come back to the first outer for
Loop now the value of I will be
incremented to 2 so 2 is less than 3 the
control will enter into the inner for
loop again then we will print the third
row of elements that is 10 12 and 78 in
the same way how we printed the first
row and the second row
after printing the third row the
condition will fail When J value is
incremented to 3 and it will enter the
auto for Loop here the I value will be
incremented again from 2 to 3 and the
condition fails now the overall control
will come out of both the for loops and
it will terminate here
so that's how we got 9 6 144 70 50 10 12
and 78. so with that we have come to the
conclusion and so far we have learned
the following things
what are two dimensional arrays why we
need two dimensional arrays syntax of 2D
arrays visualizing two Dr is
initializing two Dr is accessing 2D
elements and finally print the elements
of two dimensional Aries let's get
started with what is linked list a
linked list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes these nodes consist of
two parts data and reference to another
pointer
typically a linked list starts with a
head node which goes all the way up to
the last node which is called tail
next let's discuss why do we need linked
list a linked list is a linear data
structure like arrays but an array can
only offer a fixed size whereas a linked
list can dynamically increase its size
also operations like insertion and
deletion are much easier in a linked
list than in an array
now let's try to implement the linked
list in the code editor
start by creating a node
to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize the node we need to use
node star
the node name had
equals to
help
similarly we will create more nodes
and our last node tail
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the Heap to do that we will use a node
name
equals to
new node
star
new node braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use Arrow formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
that second node
to do that we will use add
same Arrow formation
and next
which will be equals to
our N1 node
and now we have created our first
complete node now let's create other
nodes as well
and one Arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one Arrow
next
is equals to N2
and 2 Arrow
data
is equals to
and 2 Arrow
next
to Arrow next
is equals to
tail
now tail is equals tail Arrow data
equals to 7
and
l
Arrow next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give head as the argument
as we we can only Traverse a linked list
from its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is node star
foreign
we will use while loop to Traverse this
linked list
we will give it it condition if a is not
equals to
null
then
T out
is
a data
and L
now we will change our cursor from the
current node to the next node to do that
we will use a is equals to a arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides now
let's discuss different types of linked
list the first are single linked list
next is the W linked list
the circular linked list and finally we
have the circular double A linked list
let's discuss each one of these in
details
first up single linked list it is a
unidirectional linked list
while using the synchrol linked list we
can only Traverse it in One Direction
that is from head node to the tail node
next up W linked list
it is a bi-directional linked list we
can Traverse it in both the directions
in this link list the node has an
additional pointer that points to the
previous node
next up circular linked list
it is a regular linked list except for
its last node points to the Head node
programmer needs to be careful while
traversing it or they might get stuck in
an infinite Loop
next up the circular linked list it is a
combination of w linked list and a
circular linked list
its last node points at the head node
and the previous pointer of the head
node points to the last node it is also
bi-directional linked list so that we
can Traverse it in both directions we
have now discussed the linked list why
do we need linked lists and types of
linked list now let's learn about some
operations we can apply on linked list
we can use majorly two operations on
linked list
first up insertion and deletion
we can perform these operations in three
different situations
first at the beginning at the last or at
a specific position after a node
next we will discuss these operations in
detail
first up insertion we will discuss first
insertion at the beginning
we have to give the first nodes address
to the new nodes next pointer to execute
this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give the new notes address to
the last notes reference pointer
next up insertion at a specific position
to do this we will have to change the
reference address of the previous node
to the new nodes address and the new
notes reference pointer to the next
node's address
now let's discuss deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node's
address to the null
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the reference address of
the previous node to the next node's
address
we have learned a lot about linked list
during this session now let's discuss
some benefits of linked list
first up a linked list is a dynamic data
structure that is we can dynamically
increase its size
next it offers easy insertion and
deletion than other linear data
structures like arrays and string
since it can dynamically increase its
size resulting in no memory base stage
next it is pretty handy in implementing
complex data structures like stacks and
queues Etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well
first of since the linked list is made
up of nodes it takes extra storage for
storing data and reference pointer next
the traversal in the linked list is a
bit harder than other data structure
reverse traversing is easy in doubly and
circular doubly linked list but since it
uses one extra pointer it takes extra
storage making it another limitation
let's get started with introduction to
single linked list
a single linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes these nodes
consist of two parts data and reference
to the another pointer
these notes can be traversed using
pointers
it starts from the head node all the way
up to tail node
now let's try to implement the singly
linked list in the code editor start by
creating a node
to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its members as public
the first member is int data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize the node we need to use
node star
the node name had
equals to
done
similarly we will create more nodes
and at the last repeat and our last node
tail
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the Heap to do that we will use a node
name
equals to
new node
star
new node braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use Arrow formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
that second node
to do that we will use add
same Arrow formation
and next
which will be equals to
R N1 node
and now we have created our first
complete node now let's create other
nodes as well
and one Arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one Arrow
next
is equals to N2
and 2 Arrow
data
is equals to
and 2 Arrow
next
to Arrow next
is equals to
tail
now L is equals tail Arrow data
equals to 7
and
bill
Arrow next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give head as the argument
as we we can only Traverse a linked list
from its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is node star
a
we will use while loop to Traverse this
linked list we will give it it condition
if a is not equals to
null
and
P out
is
a data
and L
now we will change
now we will change our cursor from the
current node to the next node to do that
we will use a is equals to a arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides we have
now introduced the single linked list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can apply on a linked list first up
insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situations like at the
beginning at the last or at a specific
position after a node
next up deletion similar to the
insertion we can perform it in three
different situation as well at the
beginning at the last or at a specific
position after a node
let's talk about them in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
to execute this we have to give first
notes address to the new nodes next
pointer
next up insertion at the end
to execute this we have to give new
nodes address to the last node's next
address
next up insertion at a specific position
to execute this we will change the
previous nodes a reference address to
the new notes address and the new nodes
reference pointer to the next node's
address now let's try these operations
in a code editor as you know a linked
list is made up of node so we should
start by creating a node to create a
node we need a class node
and they will Define its members as
public
and data
and
node pointer
next
now we will create a function to insert
a new node in front of the list
for this function as an argument we will
give the reference to the head of the
list
and integer dot new data
now in the definition we will allocate a
node
foreign
now we will put in the data in the new
node
we will use arrows to put to access the
data
equals to new
now we will make the next of this new
node as head
now we will move the head to point to
the new node
now we will create another function to
insert a node after a specific position
as arguments we will give it the address
to the previous node
and
repeat and the integer new data
we will first check if the given
previous node is null
if it is we will print
foreign
and then we will return the function
otherwise
otherwise we will allocate a new node
and then we will enter the new data in
there
now we will make the next of the new
node as the next of the previous node
foreign
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end of the list
as an argument we will give it
a node pointer to pointer
add
and integer new data
we will first allocate a new node
they will also create a last node
and give it
now we will put in the data in the new
node
since this new node is going to be the
last node so we will make its next as
null
now if the linked list is empty then
we'll make the new node as head
to check that we will use
if
star hat
is equals to equals to null
if it is then we will do
our head
equals to new load
else
we will Traverse it to the last node
while
last
null
asked is equals to
ask
next
now we will change the next of the last
node as new node
later
foreign
now we will write a function to print
this list
while
node is not null
code Arrow data
and then
and node
equals to
node
now we will write the code for the main
block
first we will Define a head node
and Mark it as null
now we will start using those functions
to make a linked list
first we will use append function
to add 6 in it
next let's let's use another function
push
foreign
in it
now we will try to insert one at the
beginning
so we will use push again
comma 1.
now let's try to insert 4 at the end
so far the list looks like one seven six
four null
now let's try let's try to insert 8
after 7.
to do that we will use insert
after
as argument we will use head next as 7
is present next to the Head
comma eight
now let's try to print this linked list
C out
created
then
this
print list
add
return
zip
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides now let's
talk about deletion first up deletion at
the beginning
to execute this we have to change first
nodes next address to null
next up deletion at the end
to execute this we have to change the
second last notes address to the null
next up deletion at the specific
position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
code
in this class we will declare the
members as public
print
data
and the node pointer next
now to insert a data in the node we will
use
a function push
as argument we will give pointer to
pointer node
head
and
integer new data
we will allocate a new node
we will give this new node the data as
new data
and
and new nodes next as head
foreign
now we will write a function to delete
the node
as argument we will give a node pointer
to pointer
head
and end key
now we will store head in a temp node
and we will create a node priv
as null
if head node itself holds the key to be
deleted we will use if
amp is not equals to
null
and
temp
data
is equals to equals to key
then head
equals to
foreign
next
now we will free the old node
else we will search for the key to be
deleted
else
while
amp is not equals to
Tal
and temp data
is not key
so whatever
equals to temp
and temp
will be hydrated to its next
if the key is not present in the linked
list
then we will just return the function
else we will unlink the node from the
linked list
and delete
now we will write print list function to
print the list
its argument will be a node pointer node
while
a node is not null
less than
node
data
and we will iterate this node using node
equals to
load next
now we will move on to the main block
we will start with the empty list
node
star
had
equals to null
now we will add the element to this list
so push
ampersand
had
comma 7
.
next push
it
head
comma
two
push
and percent
comma
five
next push
10 percent
add
comma
nine
now see out
created
test
print list
add
now we will use delete node function
delete
two
we will use argument as ampersion head
comma
2.
now we will check the linked list
of
2.
just
let's try and execute this
as we can see we have deleted the two
from the linked list let's get started
with an introduction to double a linked
list
a w linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
this linked list is a bi-directional
linked list that is we can Traverse it
in both Direction
these nodes consist of three parts first
up data reference to the next node and
reference to the previous node
now let's try to implement the double A
linked list in the code editor
as you know a linked list is made up of
notes so we will start by creating a
node to create a node we need a class
node
its members should be defined as public
int data
node pointer
next
and node pointer
ref
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
for it push
argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
add
and end to data
now let's allocate a node
star
new node
equals
new
note
now let's put in the data into the new
node
since we are adding at the beginning its
previous is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
node
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
we will check if head is not null
then heads previous
is equals to new node
now let's move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write a function to print the
given double A letters
its argument will be a node
we will iterate it until the node is not
null
doubt
Note data
and
node
equals to
node next
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will use a push function to push
values in the function
another push function
add
comma 3
push function
ampersand
add
comma 5.
push function
that
comma seven
now
probably
interest
and we will call the print list function
let's execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
created our first W linked list
let's get back to our slides we have now
introduced W linked list now let's
discuss some of the operations we can
perform on a doubly linked list we can
perform three operations on a w link
list first traversal
insertion and deletion
we can perform a traversal in two ways a
normal traversal and reverse traversal
and we can perform insertion and
deletion in three different situations
at the beginning at the last and at a
specific position after a node
let's discuss this in detail first up
normal traversal we can Traverse the W
linked list using our next pointer
starting from head to all the way up to
tail node
reverse traversal similar to the normal
traversal we will use previous pointer
we will start from the tail node to go
all the way up to head node
now let's try to Traverse the W linked
list in the code editor let's start by
creating a class node
we will Define its members as public
data
node pointer
next
and node pointer
ref
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
by push
its argument will be a node pointer to
pointer head
and integer new data
now we will allocate a node
are
new node
new node parenthesis
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
its pref is always null
now we will link the old node to the new
node
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now we will write a function to Traverse
the linked list normally
void Traverse
node pointer
while loop
node
is not null
therefore
e out
data
node
equals to node next
now we will write a function to reverse
traversal
its argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
add
we will create a node tail
equals to add
while
is next
is not null
this Loop is enabling us to reach to the
tail node so that we can Traverse it
from back side
now
while loop
until
is not equals to
add
key out
l
data
in
first row
Rev
yo
data
this last C out statement is only
because we are not traversing till the
head pointer
now let's go to the main block
let's start with an empty list
node star add
equals to null
now let us create a linked list to test
the function
so we will use push function
at
comma
.
another push function
Ampersand had
comma 3.
push
add
comma
7.
since we are inserting at the beginning
so the actual link list looks like
seven
five
three
now
we will print the original linked list
first see how
original
drivers
and
out
reverse traversal
first traversed
linked list
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed it in
the solid normal way as well as the
Reversed way
let's get back to our slides
next up insertion at the beginning
we will create a node with the previous
pointer pointing to a null and the next
pointer pointing to the Head node then
we will change the head nodes previous
pointer to the new node and we will
change the new node to the Head node
next up insertion at the end we have to
give the new notes address to the last
note's next pointer and change the new
node's previous pointer to the last node
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous nodes next
pointer to the new nodes and the new
nodes previous pointer to the previous
node and the next pointer to the next
node and vice versa
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class node
public
node pointer
now we will write a function push
start a note at the beginning of the
list
its argument is node pointer to pointer
add
new data
we will first allocate a new node
node star
new node
plus new
parenthesis
now we will put in the data
node Arrow data
is equals to new data
now we'll make the next of the new node
as head
and previous as null
and new node
previous
is equals to null
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
first we will check if the head node is
null
then
star head
previous
equals to new node
now I will move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write another function to
insert a node after a specific position
void
insert after
argument will be
node pointer
Rev
node
int
the data
if we first check if the given previous
node is null
yes then we will give it C out
a given node
B
none
and we will return to the function
or else we will allocate a new node
equals to new
now we will put in the data
now we will make the next of the new
node as the next of the previous node
is equals to
press
North
now I will make the next of the prep
node as new node
and make the prep node as the previous
of the new node
now I will change the previous of the
new notes next node
if
new node
next
not null
then
new node
text
Dev
is equals to new node
now let's write another function
insert a node at the end of the list
void
append
the argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
and
new data
first we will allocate a new node
equals to
new
parenthesis
now we will create another nodes last
two head
now we will put in the data
to Note data
equals to new data
now since this new node will be the last
node so its next will be null
and
is equals to a question month
in node
have
a questionna
and
star head
equals to new node
return
or else we will Traverse till the last
node
file
asked
next
is not null
last
equals to last next
now we'll make the last node as the
previous of the new node
return
now we will write a printless function
to print this list
argument is a node pointer node
while
or
is not null
code data
or is equals to node
next
now let's write the main block
we will start with an empty list
if we'll start by inserting 6 so the
linked list becomes 6 null
and
ampersand had
almost six
now we will insert 7 at the beginning
push
10 percent had
comma 7.
now we will insert one at the beginning
also
now we will insert 4 at the end
till now the linked list looks like
one
seven
six
four
none
now we will insert eight after seven
so insert
after
add
text
comma
eight
now let's print
this linked list
let's try and execute this
as we can see we have created our linked
list in the correct order
let's get back to our slide
next up deletion first up deletion at
the beginning
we have to change the first nodes next
to null and second notes previous tunnel
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last nodes
next pointer to null and delete the
previous node to free up the space
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous nodes next
pointer to the next node
and next node's previous pointer to the
previous node
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class node
click
Inc data
node pointer
next
pointer
f
now we will write a function to delete a
node in a doubly linked list
for it
delete
its argument as pointers repeat its
argument as pointer to the Head node
pointer
and pointer the node to be deleted
now we will check the base case
condition
that is if
add
is
an
or
to be deleted is null
and return
now if
the node to be deleted is a head node
then
is equals to
tell
if
next node of the Del
null
that is
if the node to be deleted is not the
last node
then
else next
equals to
else
now we will change prep only if node to
be deleted is not the first node
so if
done
Dev
not equals to
null
then
Del
Rev
X
equals to
delts next
finally
they will free the memory occupied by
the Dell
free
and
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the W linked
list
right
enter to the Head node pointer
and infinity data
we will allocate the node
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
prep is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
node
now we will change the Prem of the head
node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now let's write print list function
node pointer node
file
mode
is not equals to null
a out
data
code
goes to node
text
now let's get started with the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will create new nodes
push
percent head
comma 2
push
ampersand
add
comma 4
push
ampersand
add
comma 6
push
percent had
comma 8
now let's print this list
out
original list
now we will call the printless function
head
now we will delete the node from the W
linked list
here we are deleting the first node
next let's delete the last node
now the modified list should look like
or
eight
let's try and print this
see out
divide
hit list
head
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have deleted all the
nodes except for six and four
let's get started with introduction to
Circular linked list
a circular linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes it is like a
singular linked list except its last
node points at the head node these nodes
consist of two parts data and reference
to next pointer these nodes can be
traversed using the next pointer
now let's try to implement it in the
code editor we will start by creating
nodes
to create a node we need a class
node
we will Define its members as public
into Data
and node pointer
text
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning
void push
we will use arguments as a pointer to
node pointer add
and enter data
we will Define a node
new node
equals to new
note parenthesis
are had
now we will put in the data into a new
node
since we are inserting at the beginning
of the linked list that's why this new
nodes next should be the head pointer
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node as head
while
next
is not equals to
head
temp
is equals to
length Arrow next
then
text
equals to new node
else
new node
text
equals to
new node
star head
equals to new node
now let's write a function to print this
linked list
void
print list
load
star head
node
start temp
is equals to head
if
add is not equals to null
then
do
see out
lamp
data
and temp
equals to
temp next
now while
amp
is not equals to
head
this condition is important to stop this
Loop so that it doesn't go infinitely
now let's go to the main block
let's initialize this list as empty
code
star head
equals to null
now let's insert some nodes in this
linked list
push
and percent head
comma
push
ampersand
Ampersand head
comma 11.
head
comma
five
now this linked list looks like 5
2 then it will again go back to 5.
now let's try to print this
C out
circular
list
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first circular linked list
let's get back to our slide we have now
introduced the circular link list now
let's discuss some of the operations we
can apply on a circular link list
we can perform two operations on a
circular linked list first up insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situations at the beginning at
the last and at a specific position
after a node
next up deletion we can perform deletion
at the three different situations
first up at the beginning at the last
and at a specific position after a node
let's discuss these in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
we have to give the first notes address
to the new nodes next pointer to execute
this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give new nodes address to the
last nodes reference pointer
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous nodes
reference address to the new notes
address and the new nodes reference
pointer to the next node's address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
so far we have implemented a linked list
using classes now let's try to implement
it using structures
we will start by creating a struct node
with its element as tint data
and struct
Ure
next
now we will write a function which can
only insert a node to a empty list
struct
node
star
add empty
yeah
node
star last
comma int
new data
now since this function is only for the
empty list so we will have to check if
the linked list is empty or not
if
last
is not equals to
null
then we will return
last
now let's create a node dynamically
struct
node
start temp
equals to
construct
node
star
malloc
size of
truck
we will copy this statement because we
will need it in the future functions
we will assign the data to this new node
temp
data
is equals to
neuter
data
last
is equals to temp
now we will create the link
do that we will use last
is equals to last
since we are in an empty list so the
first node will always point to itself
return
draft
node
start we are creating a function to
insert at the beginning of the linked
list
extract
node
star add
again
as argument we will use struct
node
and data
if
last
is equals to null
then we will return
empty
last
comma data
now we will create a node dynamically
I've already copied this statement for
the ease
now we will put in the data
is equals to data
and
next
is equals to
asked
next
last
is equals to
return
last
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end
product
node
star
add
and
start
mode
last
hint
if
last equals to equals to null
then
returned
add empty
last
comma data
now we will dynamically create a node
and put in the data
damn
equals to data
temp
next
is equals to
last
text
now last next
is equals to temp
and last equals to
temp
return
now we will write a function to insert a
node after a specific node
so struct
ured
star
add after
product
load
star
cast
comma
connect data
and
item
this item is a node after which we have
to insert the node
if
last
null
then
return
Ed
node
are temp
comma star p
B is equals to last next
Now do
if if
goes to
heightened
then
equals to
we will dynamically create a node here
temp
is equals to
product
start
lock
size of
product
load
now we will put in the data so temp
data is equals to data
temp
next
is equals to
text
a p next
is equals to temp
if
e is equals to last
and last
is equals to 10.
return
equals to P next
while
not equals to
last
text
out
item
not
present
in the list
return
last
now we will write a function to print
this list
void
print list
struct
node
start last
now if
last is equals to null
then
C out
test is empty
and return
else we will point to the first node of
the list so p is equals to
last
text
to Traverse the list we will use do well
Loop
so do
C out
DotA
is equals to
be next
while
e is not equals to
last
text
now
let's write a code for the main block
we will start with an empty list
struct
node
are
last
two null
now last is equals to
add
empty
last
comma
six
cost equals to
add begin
passed comma
four
last
equals to add begin
comma 2.
last equals to
add and
past comma
12.
first
equals to
add
after
last
comma
done
comma 4.
print list
thoughts
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the link
list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides
now let's talk about deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last notes
address to null to execute this
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous nodes
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in the
code editor
let's get started with creating a node
to create a node we need a class
node
we will declare its members as public
and data
node pointer
next
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the list
void
push
a pointer to the node pointer header
and and new data
now let's create a node and make add as
next of it
node
star
equals to new
load parenthesis
let's put in the data new node
data is equals to new data
and
new node
next
is equals to
add
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node
as the first node
if
star head
not null
then we will find the node before head
and update next to it
so node star
temp
is equals to Star head
oil
jump next
is not
equals to add
temp is equals to
temp next
equals to
new node
else
next
is equals to new node
and star head
now let's write a function to delete a
given node from the list
so void
delete
its argument is a pointer to the node
pointer
add
key
now if linked list is empty then we will
simply return it
if
star head
goes to null
then return
it otherwise if
add
data
is equals to T
and
add
next
is equals to head
then
free
add
is equals to none
return
now
node
last
is equals to
star head
comma study
now if head is to be deleted
then
star head
data
is equals to
e
then
while
last
equals to
star head
then last
is equals to last next
now we will point the last note to the
second node of the list
now we'll free this ad
equals to
last next
now if either the node to be deleted is
not found or the end of the list is not
released then
file
last
is not equals to
head
and
last
data
is not equals to key
then
last equals to
last
if not to be deleted was found then
if
last
data
is equals to key
then D is equals to last
next
and last
is equals to D is next
now we will free d
or else
see
out
no such
e
found
now let's write a function to print this
list
void
and list
node star
add
temp
is equals to add
f
had
not null
then do
C out
lamp
data
amp is equals to
ramp next
while
amp
is not equals to that
C out
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start by empty list
so node star
add
equals to
null
now we will push
ten percent had
push
Ampersand thread
comma five
push
Ampersand had
comma seven
push
10 percent head
comma
eight
and push
Ampersand head
comma 10.
now we will print the list before any
deletion operation
see out
list
before
you should
print list
had
now let's delete
add
let's delete seven
see out
rest
after deletion
print list
right
let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly in this particular
session we will discuss the differences
between the two major data structures
that are the arrays and linked lists so
at first what exactly is an array so an
array is a linear data structure that
stores homogeneous data elements in a
continuous form so homogeneous in the
sense you will be able to store only one
single data type of elements in an array
for example consider that you have
declared an array and you wanted to
store some elements in the array so you
can declare a data type first after that
the name of the array and if you declare
that the array should store integer data
type then you can only store integer
elements in that particular data type
you cannot store any other data type
like float or character that is the
meaning of this particular definition
and it stores the elements in a
continuous order that is in the adjacent
format as you can see in the example
here 10 20 30 40 and which are located
in the adjacent location status 0 1 2
and 3. now let us understand what
exactly is a linked list
so similar to Ari even a linked list is
a linear data structure but the only
difference is it has a dynamic data
structure here you can increase or
decrease the size of the linked list in
runtime the only difference is here the
memory locations are not adjacent to
each other but they are taken from the
memory here so there is a huge memory
chunk out of that the linked list will
borrow some of the memory locations and
one after the other the memory nodes
will be interconnected using pointers so
that was the difference between array
and linked list and similar to arrays
even the linked lists store homogeneous
type of elements that is if you declare
a linked list of node data type then you
can only store float data type in it you
cannot store any other different data
type like character or string
now followed by that let us understand
the types of arrays so basically we have
three different types of arrays those
are the one dimensional arrays and
inside multi-dimensional arrays we find
two more types those are the two
dimensional arrays and three dimensional
arrays now one dimensional arrays will
be having only one subscript that is
where they'll be having only one single
row whereas in the two dimensional
arrays we will be having two subscripts
that is it will be having rows and
columns and in the three dimensional
arrays it will be having three
subscripts that is the row column and
the block address now followed by the
types of arrays we will understand the
types of linked lists
so similar to arrays even linked lists
are divided into three types they are
singly linked list doubly linked list
and circular linked list the difference
between them is a singly linked list
will have two parts that is the node
address and node element in this
particular segment the element will be
stored and in this particular second
segment the address that points that the
next node will be saved and similarly in
the circular linked list the only
difference between the single linked
list and the circular linked list is at
the end of the single event list we can
see a null pointer which indicates the
end of the linked list but in circular
linked list the address will not be null
instead it will point back to the Head
node that is what which makes it as a
circular typed singly linked list or a
circular linked list when it comes to
the third type that is the doubly linked
list we can see there are two address
locations the first starting node will
have null as its first address location
then we'll store the element I and the
second address location will point to
the next node and you can see in the
second node we'll have element and the
first address location will point to the
previous node and the second address
location will point to the next node and
at the end the second address location
will be pointed as null which indicates
as the end of the linked list now that
we know the types of linked list and
arrays we will look into the fundamental
differences between arrays and linked
lists
so the First Fundamental differences
between the arrays and linked list is
the array element can be accessed
randomly using just the index values but
whereas Random Access is not possible in
linked list if you want to access any
element in linked list you need to
perform the Traverse operation
sequentially
the second difference between the both
is array is static which means memory
size is fixed which cannot be changed in
runtime but whereas in the linked list
the memory is dynamic which means you
can either shrink or expand the memory
in runtime according to your
requirements
followed by that the next difference is
each element in Array is independent in
nature that is you can access any
element just by giving the index
location whereas in linked list the
elements are interdependent on each
other whenever you want to access a
specific element you need to go through
the other elements or Traverse through
the other elements
next one is the array takes more time in
operations like insertion and deletion
whereas link this takes less time to
perform the operations of insertion and
delete
followed by that the next reference is
accessing any element is faster in Array
as random access is possible and the
array data structure just by using its
index values but whereas accessing an
element in linked list is slow because
we know that we need to Traverse through
all the node elements to access a
particular element
now the next difference is in case of an
array memory allocation is done in
compile time whereas in linked list the
memory allocation is done during the
runtime
memory utilization is inefficient in an
array as it is allocated as in static
and it is allocated during the compile
time in case of linked list the memory
utilization is very efficient as the
memory is allocated during the run time
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
what is a stack
so basically stack is a linear data
structure just like arrays and linked
lists the only difference is that it
follows a specific order when an
operation is implemented on it so what
is the specific order that it follows
that is lifo last and first out or filo
first and last out in the next part we
will understand this order in a much
better way
all operations can be done only at the
one end of the stack that is on the top
now we will discuss much about that in
the operations part of the stack now let
us understand the First Fundamental that
is a representation of Stack that is how
do you represent a stack normally
so a stack can be represented using two
different methods that is using an array
or using a linked list so in an array we
will be using the continuous memory
and in stack we will be using a
non-continuous memory and the stack will
behave like a dynamic stack or a dynamic
data structure
now the first method that is the array
method
so in this method an array is used to
represent the stack as you can see in
the image below we have a stack
so the name of the stack is stack itself
and you can see two more things here
that is dot is equal to 2 and Max is 4.
so the max is the value of the array or
the length of the array the maximum
length of the array and top is the
position where the last element of the
stack is present here in this case 56 is
the last element in the stack and top is
inclined or it is addressing to that
particular address that is 2.
and now let us discuss about the linked
list representation of Stack
so in this method a dynamic data
structure that is a linked list is used
to represent the stack this
representation leads leads to a dynamic
stack it does not need to define the
maximum number of elements present in
the stack remember in arrays we had to
define the max value in the previous
example we had the max value as 5 but in
here you need not to assign the max
value as the stack itself is dynamic
the pointers links are used to store the
address of the upcoming notes and the
variable used in this method is top so
the top is holding the address of the
topmost element in the linked list
representing the stack
now moving ahead we shall understand the
basic operations on stack now here we
will understand the previously discussed
definition that is Push Pull Etc in a
much better way so the basic operations
on a stack are push pop or pull and Peak
now let us discuss each one of them in a
detailed way the first one is push
operation so the push operation is the
mechanism of inserting a new element
into the stack
as you can see we are trying to insert
the elements from the top so the push
operation basically involves the
following steps check if the stack is
either full or not so basically whenever
you are trying to insert an element into
the stack you need to make sure that the
stack is empty or it has some space if
it is full you cannot insert an element
into the stack Step 2 if the stack is
full produce an error and exit that's
what I was talking about now the step
three
if the stack is not full increment the
top by one that is when you're inserting
an element then you need to update the
top value for example in the previous
slide when we had the array
representation of a stack we had the Top
Value as 2. so if you try to include an
element into the stack then you need to
update the Top Value from 2 to 3 that is
incremented by one
now the fourth step add data elements to
the stack where the top is pointing
and finally success the push operation
has been successful so this is how you
insert or push an element into the stack
now followed by push operation we have
pop or pull
so the pop operation is a mechanism of
eliminating or deleting or removing one
data element from the existing stack
so we shall understand the pop operation
in a much more detailed way the
operation involves checking the stack is
empty or not if in case the stack is not
empty then you can carry forward the pop
operation but in case if the stack is
empty then you have to provide an exit
status and exit the control and leave
the stack
so if the stack is not empty approach
the data element at the top that is at
the top position for example in the
previous array example remember right we
had the top position pointing towards
two so you need to take the control to
the top position and pick out the
element and popped
and finally decrease the top by one so
when you eliminate the top element then
the Top Value from 2 will be decremented
to one so this is how the pop operation
is carried over on a stack
next one is
the peak operation the peak operation
involves returning the topmost data
element from the stack without moving it
so here you can see the top is pointing
to the element number four and you're
picking the element number four and
you're not removing it from the stack
you're just returning the topmost data
element you're passing the value of the
top element
so to understand the push pop and Peak
operations on stack in a much more
better way let's carry out a practical
example now we are on the Practical mode
and here you can see on my screen we
have the code example for this stack now
first we'll be checking if the stack is
empty as per the steps mentioned in the
previous discussion we will check if the
stack is empty or not if it is empty
then we will return else we will
continue and again another step we also
check if the stack is full if the stack
is full we will accept else we will
continue with the operation whatever it
is Peak pop or push and here we have an
example for the peak operation that we
discussed previously and followed by
that we have a pop operation we are
trying to exclude an element from the
stack and another one we have the push
operation where we'll be trying to push
the elements into the stack so these are
the three functions for push pop and
Peak now we'll try to push in the
elements and also pop and
try to involve some functions on it or
run some operations on the stack now
let's run this code and see the output
so you can see that the code has
successfully executed and we have the
statements here the first one says the
stack is not full that is false and
stack is empty that is true right and
after that you can see that the elements
which we try to push into the stack that
is 1176 71 15 and 66 are been pushed
into the stack and if you clearly
observe it we have The Element 11 in the
bottom 76 upon that 71 upon that and 15
and last 66 so the order is first in
last out that is the first element was
pushed first and when you are trying to
eliminate the elements from the stack
then you will first pick out 66 followed
by that you will pick out 15 followed by
that you will pick out 71 and so on so
this is the rule what stack follows now
I hope I made myself clear with the
example now we should continue with the
applications of
so these are the few applications of
Stack the first one is expression
conversion so you can see we have the
infix notation prefix notation and post
fixed notation so the infix notation is
no rocket science there is only one
thing here to learn that is we have two
operands A and B and we have one
operator that is the addition operator
in between those two operands
and when you use the prefix notation you
will have the operator located at the
first place then you will have the
operands followed by it and in the post
fix one you will have the operands first
and followed by the operands you will
have the operator
so basically all the infects prefix and
postfic notations give out the same
results for the only difference is the
representation of those operands and
operators
now let us understand this in a much
more detailed way
so conversion of expression from one
form to another form is the main
application of Stack so we have the
first one that is infix to prefix and
infix to post fix now let us see an
example here you have one plus two star
three plus four so this is the normal
infix notation and when you try to
present the same expression in the form
of prefix notation so this will be the
result and this is a result for post
Twix
the next one prefix to post fix and
prefix to infix and this is the way you
write the prefix notation and if you
want to convert that to infects this is
how you can write it and this happens to
be the result of post fixed notation
and finally post fixed or prefix postfix
to infix and these are the results
now followed by expression evaluation
the next important application of Stack
is checking parenthesis
and you can see if the parenthesis is
set properly the expression gets
evaluated if not it will not be
evaluated
now the last one memory management and
function call the very useful thing of
using a stack is
the memory will not be allocated to your
stack elements unless the function is
called here you can see it is the main
function and these are the elements that
you wanted to declare into your stack
and unless you make a function call the
elements will not be declared their
memory or the elements will not get the
memory allocated for them
now another good application of Stack as
the backtracking problem or the end
Queen problem
the end Queen problem is an example of
backtracking cropping the end grain
solution to this problem is to position
the queen in such a way that the
opponent Queen cannot attack your queen
now another example is string reversal
you can see on my screen we have a
string that is a b c d and e Now using
Stacks you can reverse this
right so you're basically eliminating an
element and relocating it to the first
place
and finally after reversing your string
this will be your result A B C D and E
followed by that we have conversion
evaluation
so stack is used to evaluating the
expression as shown in the example
since parenthesis has the highest
precedence 5 plus 4 gets evaluated first
and it will result in 9. then
multiplication and division have the
same precedence now the associativity
comes into picture so the associativity
is always from left to right so first 4
into 9 will be executed which will
result in 36 and then 32 divided by 4
which will give us 8.
now we have 36 minus 8 which will give
us an answer that is 26. now the last
application is the Tower of Hanoi so the
Tower of Hanoi is a mathematical puzzle
consisting of three rods and N discs
this puzzle consists of some rules the
first rule states that wonders can move
only at a time the second rule is that
the disc can only be moved when it is at
the uppermost position on the stack
the third one no disc is allowed to
place on the top of the smaller disk
so this is how the Tower of Hanoi Works
what is the stack
so stack is a linear data structure that
follows fifo or first and first out
principle all the operations on the
stack are done only from one end that is
the top
so you can see this image here and this
particular image of books can be
considered as stack and you can see that
the addition or elimination of elements
that a spokes in this particular case is
happening only through the top section
foreign
now we will understand what are the
basic operations that can be performed
on a stack so the basic operations that
can be performed on a stack are push pop
and Peak
so this particular image on the right
side will help you understand what
exactly is push pop and Peak as we
discussed the elements will be added
into the stack from the top so when you
add an element from the outside into the
stack it will be pushed from the top
that is the push operation and if you
want to eliminate an element from the
stack it will be eliminated from the top
that is the pop operation apart from
these two that is push and pop we have
another operation that is called as Peak
the main intention of p is just to see
the element which is on the topmost part
of the stack it will just retrieve the
element from the top it will not pop it
or it will not push any other element
onto the top it will just copy and it
will just print what is present on the
top so these are the main operation
status push pop and Peak
now let us see how to implement this
stack using array
so implementation of Stack data
structure can be done in two ways that
is array and linked list
now in this particular session we will
learn how to implement stack using array
data structure now without further Ado
let's get started with the
implementation of Stack
so we will be performing push operation
that is inserting a new element into the
stack
now followed by that we will be
performing the pop operation onto the
stack that is eliminating or deleting an
element from the top position of the
stack
and followed by that the last operation
that is the peak operation where we will
be just retrieving the topmost element
from the stack without removing that
element from the stack or without adding
any new element to the stack now that we
have a detailed understanding of what
are the basic operations that can be
applied onto the stack let's get started
with the Practical implementation
now you can see that on my screen we
have the basic fundamental operations
Ultra stack that has the push and pop
now without further Ado let's get
started with running this code don't
worry about the code this particular
code will be present in the description
box below or if you need it you can
always write down to us in the comment
section below and we will have it sent
to your mail ID so that you can have a
better understanding of the code and try
to execute the code in your local system
now let's run the code and see the
output
as you can see the code got successfully
executed and the top post element is a
and the topmost element is B after the
element is being popped away and it says
that the element B was popped out and
after that the topmost element was a and
after that the element a was also popped
out and now the top is pointing to -1
which means to say that the stack is
empty
in this session we will learn about
linked list implementation using stack
so first up what exactly is a linked
list so linked list is a dynamic data
structure it allocates memory
dynamically the nodes are maintained in
a non-continuous memory that is in
linked list we have nodes so each and
every node is connected via a pointer
which points to the address of the next
node
each node contains next pointer that is
the next Pointer's address which gives
the reference to the next node and it
also has another section which stores
the data the topmost node always
contains null in its address
and this is how a linked list looks like
so this is the top which is the
beginning position of the linked list
and this is the address of the first
location and this is the next node this
is the following node then this is the
last node and this points back to the
Head node so this is how you can
Implement a stack like data structure
using linked list you can see that we
can perform stack like operation that is
the elements are located one above the
other and the top is pointing to the
Head node now let us go through the
implementation of stat using linked list
first we will go through traversing off
stack using linked list so displaying
each node of the linked list
representing stack is termed as
traversing copy the head pointer to the
temporary pointer and then move
temporary node through all the nodes and
display values of each node
so you can see the animation here will
explain you how the traversal goes
through the linked list in real time
now another linked list implementation
of Stack is the push operation
so adding a new node to the top of the
stack as termed as push operation
generally in stack we have three
operations that is push pop and Peak so
one of the operation is push where you
add an element into the stack in the
same way using linked list you can add a
new node to the stack and point it as
the top of the stack or the first
element which represents the top in
terms of Stack
now create a node first and allocate a
new memory to it if the list is empty
and node consists of data and null is
the address it will be inserted as the
first node if there is some node already
existing then add a new node at the
beginning to avoid violations
so the following animation will help you
understand how we add a new element or
the top element to the stack using
linked lists
now followed by the push operation we
have the pop operation
so now let us go through the pop
operation removing a node from the top
of the stack is turned as Pop operation
in the same way we will be eliminating
the first node from the linked list
which is termed as Dot
underflow condition may occur when you
try to remove the node if the stack is
already empty in stack node can be
removed from one and only therefore the
value stored in the head pointer must be
deleted and the node must be free
followed by the pop operation we have
the peak operation
retrieving the topmost node of the
linked list representing stack without
removing the linked list node from the
top of the stack external speak
operation generally when you are using a
stack data structure just retrieving the
value of the top node is called as Peak
operation you are not going to eliminate
or you are not going to add a new
element to the top we are just going to
copy the element or you are just going
to retrieve the element which is pointed
as Top This operation is called as Peak
now in the linked list you can also
perform this operation of peak now with
the theory discussed let us execute a
practical program based on stack
implementation using linked list
now on my screen you can see a code
example using which we will Implement
stack using a linked list now here we
have the pop Operation Push operation
and top and then the main function don't
worry about the code this particular
code snippet will be attached in the
description box below or you can also
request us and we will have it sent to
your mail ID and you can understand the
code and try executing in your local
system now without further Ado let's
directly run the code
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled and we have tried
to add some elements into the stack that
is A B C and C is being the topmost
element of the stack and that element
has got popped and followed by that the
element on the top currently after C
being popped.s B and the node element B
got popped again and the only element
which was present in the stack is a and
that element is also popped out after
performing the pop operation and now
currently this stack is empty you can
see that we have tried to push the
elements a b c and also we try to pop
the elements APC okay let's get started
with introduction to Q you know that all
of us depend on messaging applications
like WhatsApp Facebook Messenger
Instagram chats to communicate with
offerings and family members and while
using them you must have observed that
the person you are trying to communicate
with receives messages in the same order
as you have sent them now the question
that arises theories how is this
happening how are these applications
maintaining the order of these text
messages and the solution to these
questions bring us to queue basically in
these applications a queue is maintained
for each user containing the messages to
be delivered to the user
when the user connects to the network
all the text messages in the queue gets
delivered and once the messages are
delivered mtqs get deleted
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of data structures so let's
dive further and understand the
structure of the queue in depth
but before doing that let's look at a
real life example of cues to understand
it more clearly
the most common and relevant example of
a queue is a movie ticket counter
in the movie ticket counter you must
have observed that both of its ends
remain open also these ends are fixed
with the help of parakeets and that is
why no one can enter in between these
ticket lines
Additionally the person who enters first
receives a ticket first and the person
who enters last will obviously get
served at last cues and data structure
resembles all these properties of a
movie ticket counter which makes them
better at creating virtual first come
first serve systems basically they are
defined as a linear collection of
different data types that allow
insertion at one end and deletion at
another
unlike any other data structure the
queue ends remain open allowing it to
have different functionalities at both
ends the end at which insertion takes
place is called rare
and the end at which deletion takes
place is known as front
furthermore there are two approaches to
consider the structure of the queue and
both of them depend on the approach of
the programmer that means being a
programmer if you consider the left tent
as front then your rare note will be at
Right End otherwise if you consider the
left hand as rare then the Right End
will be your cue's front node
unlike Aries and linked lists elements
in the queue cannot be operated from
their respective locations here they can
only be operated from the front or rear
position moving on let's discuss the
operations in Q data structures one by
one
the first operation is enqueue it is
used to store the elements in the queue
next up is DQ this operation is used for
removing them
further we have is full and isnal
operations is full function scrutinizes
if the queue is full or not and the is
null operation evaluates if the queue is
empty
we also have a peak operation that helps
you get the element from the front of
the queue without removing it
let's Now understand how these
operations work with the help of the
following examples
here we will look at nq5 and q1 and Q
minus 2 then is full then DQ Peak and is
null
but before explaining these operations
it's essential that we initialize the Q
data structure by assigning some random
size to it
for example intq of 3 by this
declaration we are assigning only three
spaces for insertion in Cube
also at this phase there is no element
in the queue as it's empty so both the
front node and rare node will point to
the same location with null memory space
in the storage system let's consider
that null index to be -1 for ease of our
convention now the first operation on
our list is NQ of 5.
as we discussed previously NQ operation
is nothing but the insertion of data
into a queue data structure it begins
with checking if the queue is full or
not
if the queue is full then the previously
assigned memory is completely filled
with data elements so insertion would
not be possible this is also known as
overflow error in terms of programming
but as a queue is empty so the insertion
can be performed here for that we have
to increment the rare pointer to index 0
from index -1
and once we do that the data element Phi
will be added to the queue also for
front insertion both front and rear will
point to the same location as there is
only one element present in this queue
let's insert two more elements into this
queue with the operations in q1 and then
Q minus 2.
for that we have to increment the red
pointer to the next index which will be
1.
now as the point is incremented so the
data will be entered into this position
next up is NQ minus 2. again we have to
follow the same process of incrementing
the rare pointer we will increment the
rare pointer to point towards the next
index that is index 2 and hence the data
element with value minus 2 will be
entered here
the next operation on our list is is
full
in this operation if the rare pointer
points to the max size then the queue is
considered to be full as there is no
space left for insertion in our case the
max size of RQ is 12 bytes
additionally we are considering to enter
only three integer elements
and one integer data element takes four
bytes of the memory space that means
three integer elements will take 12
bytes hence this function will prompt Q
is full on the screen
now we will discuss the DQ operation if
we want to access data from a queue we
have to perform two subtasks the first
one is access the data where the front
is pointing and another is to remove the
data after axis and this complete
process is called as DQ operation
the first step of this operation is to
check if the queue is empty
if the queue is empty then there is no
element available for deletion this is a
case of underflow error
but SRQ is not empty we can proceed with
the next steps we will be accessing data
from the front node and later we will be
incrementing the front pointer in order
to remove the link to the previous node
so that the data gets removed now front
will point to the index 1.
thus the data value Phi will be removed
from the queue and will also be prompted
on the screen therefore this function
comes with an integer return type
next up is Peak operation
in this operation element at the front
node will be accessed without deleting
it
the algorithm for this operation begins
with checking if the queue is empty or
not
if the queue is not empty then data at
the front node will be accessed with
temporary variable and printed on the
screen
advancing further let's perform two more
DQ operations here first is DQ of 1 and
another one is DQ of minus 2.
the data at the front node will be
accessed primarily and the front pointer
will be incremented to point to the next
data element
when we do the point incrementation the
link to the previous node gets removed
which results in data deletion
similarly we will perform a DQ of minus
2 operation here now the front will be
pointed to null memory space as there is
no element left in RQ and the data minus
2 will be removed
the last operation on our list is smt
this function checks if the queue is
empty or not in the previous procedure
we mentioned that if the front points to
the null memory space then the queue is
empty and in our case the front is
already pointing to -1
so the output of this function will be Q
is empty
this is all about operations in the
queue I hope that you all are clear with
these operations
next we will discuss different types of
cues and their structures at a glance
basically there are four types of cues
linear queue circular queue priority
queue and double ended queue
the structure which we have discussed
till this time is that of a linear queue
so now we will move on to Circular queue
the circular queue is almost similar to
the linear queue except that the last
node of this queue is connected to the
first
it is also known as ring buffer as all
the ends are connected to another end
additionally this circular queue is a
better version of the linear queue as it
removes the drawback of insertion in the
linear queue
the empty space available in a circular
queue can be filled with the new element
by simply incrementing the value of the
rare position we will learn about this
in detail in the further sessions
a priority queue is another special type
of queue data structure in which each
element has some priority assigned with
it
based on the priority of each element
the elements are arranged in a priority
queue if the elements occur with the
same priority then they are served
according to the first and first out
principle
in the priority queue the insertion
occurs based on the arrival while the
deletion occurs based on the priority
the above figure shows that the highest
priority element comes first and the
elements of the same priority are
arranged based on the first and first
out structure
the last type of queue is DQ
DQ is a linear data structure in which
the insertion and deletion operations
are performed from both the ends we can
say that DQ is a generalized version of
the queue
DQ can be used as stack as well as Q as
it allows the insertion and deletion
operations on both the ends
if the insertion takes place at one end
and deletion at another then that EQ is
known as a linear queue and if both
addition and deletion are performed at a
single end then that EQ is called stack
advancing further let's discuss some
applications of cues to gauge an insight
into the importance of cues
the Q data structure is used in
computers printers and applications to
utilize the benefits of the first come
first serve technique
in computers whenever you work on
documents or ppts you must have observed
that whichever key you press on the
keyboard appears in the exact same order
on the screen but when your processor is
too busy with other tasks you might
notice that the keys you press appear on
the screen with some delay after you
press them basically those keys are
stored in queue and when the processor
becomes free it processes in the order
the keys are pressed that means the key
pressed first will be written in a Word
document first
so this is how computers use a queue to
eliminate Deadlocks when multiple
processes are in a ready state
next up is printers
a queue data structure is used in
Printers to maintain the order of pages
while printing that means the pages are
stored in a queue in the order that you
want to print them and once the page is
removed from an ordered queue it gets
printed
another most common application of queue
data structure is their usage in web or
mobile apps
applications like Domino's swiggy uses a
queue for maintaining food order status
if you place an order from an online
portal your order ID enters the queue
and once the previous orders before your
order ID gets catered then your order
will be catered as well
from these examples we can clearly say
that cues are used Whenever there is a
need for an fcfs strategy in software
development so whenever you work on
projects that need a first come first
serve approach then remember that you
have to implement a q data structure to
complete it successfully
finally let's have a look at some key
takeaways that we discussed in this
session
we started this session by examining the
structure of the queue we learned that
the queue is a linear data structure
after that we talked about different
operations of queues in which we learned
NQ and DQ are responsible for data
manipulation in a queue later we discuss
different types of queues as well
finally we discovered some applications
of cues and how they fulfill the need of
fcfs systems
we have also made it clear that queues
can handle multiple data types as well
having said that let's dive deep into
the strategy to implement Q data
structure until now we have understood
that Q is a special kind of list with
some restrictions on insertion and
deletion and there are two approaches to
deal with queue implementation the first
one is array based and another one is
linked list based in this session we are
going to focus on array based
implementation
initially let's say we want to create a
queue of integer elements for that
purpose firstly it is essential to
declare an array of random spaces let's
take 100 as the size of rre that means
our array can have a maximum of 100
integer elements the Declaration of an
array is made with this line of code
intq 100
where into represents integer data type
and Q is the name of our array and
hundred is its size
the area that we just initialized is
going to store our queue by that what I
mean is at any random index of an array
queue is going to start with two Mark
tense front and rear
in this array I am showing front of the
queue towards the left and rev towards
the right
for making those end nodes we need to
initialize two pointers front and rear
at this moment as RQ is empty so both of
those pointers should Point towards -1
so initialization of these pointers
should be done as inch front is equal to
-1 and intraer is equal to -1 when the
insertion or deletion happens in queues
these pointers will be either
incremented or decremented so they are
an essential part of this queue
implementation process
now you must be clear with the array and
pointers declaration part so let's dive
further and formulate code for queue
implementation using a one-dimensional
array in C plus plus
it is essential to include header files
into our source file as we cannot access
standard C plus functionalities without
them
that is why here we are going to load
iostream and standard input output files
along with using meme space sdd
once this is done we will initialize our
array along with front and rash pointers
remember we always have to declare the
size of an array before compilation that
means we cannot update the size of an
array at runtime
this scenario is the biggest limitation
of queue implementation using arrays
having said that let's proceed with
Pointer's declaration
now we are done with the initialization
process we will now work on
implementation of queue functionalities
let's first work out supportive Q
functions like is null is full and Peak
Isner function validates if the queue is
empty
and as per our previous discussion when
both front and rare points to -1 then
the queue is considered to be empty
so the condition to determine if Q is
empty will be
if rare is equal to is equal to -1 and
front is equal to is equal to -1 it will
return Q is empty
if the queue does not satisfy the
previous condition then it is not empty
so by using the else condition we can
display the queue is not empty
next up is is full function this
function validates if the queue is full
and we can clearly say that if the rare
pointer is equal to the max size of the
queue then RQ is going to be completely
full
next is peak
the peak function extracts the element
where the front pointer is pointing
without removing it from the queue
for this functionality to work our queue
must contain data elements in it what I
mean is RQ should not be empty if RQ is
not empty then data at the front node
can be accessed
this is how we Implement supportive Q
functions let's immediately dive into
the development of main queue operations
NQ and DQ
for enqueue operation if the queue is
full then our function should prompt an
overflow error for that to happen we
have to put this condition
if the front pointer is pointing to -1
then we have to increment the front
pointer to zero manually
otherwise it can be incremented by Rare
plus plus
after pointer incrementation we have to
ask for a data element to enter into the
queue once the data is given it should
be inserted at the position where the
rare is pointing now
finally let's code the final main queue
operation called as DQ
if the queue is empty then there is no
element for deletion so it should prompt
an underflow error on screen
also if there is only one element left
inside Q then both pointers should again
be pointed towards -1
for that let's write another condition
here
if both the previously mentioned
conditions are false then deletion of an
element can be achieved by just pointer
incrementation
we have implemented all the Q
functionalities here but we haven't
implemented a function that can show us
how our queue looks so for that let's
Implement one more function with the
name display
this function should prompt the elements
of the queue on the screen
elements will only be printed if the
queue is not empty hence we have to
check for the emptiness of the queue
first
finally we are done with the hard part
so let's arrive at the main function to
contemplate these operations in order to
visualize outputs
we are going to use a switch case to
take a user command thus not to waste
your time on this let me just get done
with this block ASAP
that's all we are done with the queue
implementation using arrays let's just
examine if our code works fine or Not by
compiling it
this program should return a console
that asks the user to give commands for
performing different operations
so as you can see on your screens if I
input 1 I can perform insertion in a
queue
let's perform some insertions now we
will insert four elements first three
then 21
next 78
and finally 12.
after inserting these elements we will
print the state of the queue using case
3.
now let's also check the DQ function
if we perform a DQ operation then 3
should be removed from the queue let's
check if it is remote using the display
function
and yes our code works just fine
now if you're concerned about this code
then don't be as we can send it over to
you if you drop your email IDs in the
comment section below
Additionally you can also try to run it
on your local system to have a better
understanding of the concept
when we discuss the implementation of
queue using arrays we discuss the
limitation of big size according to that
limitation an array will always have a
fixed size and it should be declared
before the compilation of program
furthermore once all the positions in an
array are taken or it is exhausted then
we only have two options we can either
deny insertion by saying that the queue
is full and we cannot insert anything
now or what we can do is we can create a
new larger array and copy elements from
the previous array to the new large
array the time complexity for this copy
operation will be proportional to the
number of elements inside field array in
other words we can say that the time
complexity of this copy operation will
be Big O of n but again as we are giving
random larger size to the array there is
a possibility of massive memory loss
like right now in this area 70 of the
memory is unused and the memory is a
crucial resource that we should
it's not that some amount of unused
memory will be real problem in today's
modern day computer but it's just that
while designing Solutions and algorithms
we should always analyze and understand
these implications regarding memory
along with this memory wastage there
exists another sort of memory management
issue that occurs while utilizing an
array to implement a queue data
structure the space of an array which is
used to store elements can never be
reused to store the queue elements
because items can only be inserted from
the front end and the front end's value
may be so high at that time the space
before the pointer will be lost for
eternity let's have a look at an example
to understand this drawback more clearly
in this example of array representation
of q a q of size 10 having 5 elements is
shown the value of the print pointer is
5. therefore we cannot reinsert values
in the place of already deleted elements
before the position of front that means
the space of the array before front
pointer can never be reused for storage
purpose
these drawbacks represents the need for
a more appropriate method to implement
queues and by using a proper Dynamic
data structure like linked list these
drawbacks can be easily removed on that
note let's discuss about the
representation of Q using a linked list
a link list as we know is a collection
of data elements that we call nodes
these nodes are stored at non-contiguous
locations in memory further each node
contains two field one to store data and
another to store the address of next
field or the reference to the next node
let's assume that the node in this
figure are at addresses 200 400 and 500
respectively I have filled these
addresses in the address field as well
the identity of the link list that we
always give with us is address of the
head node we often name a pointer or
reference variable at which we store the
address as head
so now we are saying that we want to use
a linked list to implement queue data
structure and the basic definition of
queue conveys that a queue is a linear
data structure in which insertion is
performed at the rear node and deletion
at the front node it's really effortless
to enforce this property of a queue in
linked list we can simply pick one side
of a linked list for insertion and
another site for deletion if the head
node is considered to be print then the
tail node will be the rear otherwise if
the head node is deemed to be the rear
then the tail node will be the printing
whatever side we are picking for
whatever operation we just need to make
sure one thing and that thing is the
operations that we are carrying out must
take a constant time or in other words
that time complexity should be big of 1.
I hope that you guys are clear with the
representation of a link list as a queue
data structure now moving forward we
will discuss about its implementation
but before that let's have a look at the
time complexity management challenge
which occurs in queue implementation of
a link list
in the case of linked list the cost for
insertion or removal from the head side
is Big off one but the cost for
insertion or removal from the tail side
is Big of n so here is the deal in a
standard implementation of Q using link
list if we insert element at one side
and remove them from other side then one
of these operation NQ or DQ depending on
how we are picking this side will cost
us bigger of n but the requirement that
we have specified before for queue
implementation suggest that both these
operations must take a constant time
so we'll definitely need to do something
to ensure that both NQ and DQ operations
take constant time let's call this side
front and this side rear so I want to
enqueue a node from the tail site and I
want to perform a DQ at the head side we
are good for DK operation because
removal from the front will take a
constant time but insertion or enqueue
operation will be costing us big of n
let's first see why insertion at the
tail will be costlier and then maybe we
can try to do something to insert an
element at the rear end what we will
have to do is first we'll have to create
a node let's say I have got this node at
address 350 and the integer that I want
to enqueue is 7. the address part of
this node can be set as null now we have
to build a link with this created new
node and to do that first we'll set the
address part of the last node as the
address part of this newly created node
but the only identity that we always
keep with us in case of linked list is
address part of head node so to get
appointed to any other node we need to
start at head that is why first we'll
create a pointer variable term and will
initially set it to head node and now
using this 10 pointer we'll try hours to
the end of our linked list that is the
tail node and here using this pointer
temp we can write the address part of
the newly created node at the previous
tail node to build this new link
this traversal of pointer from head to
tail is taking all the time for
insertion we use a statement like temp
is equal to temp.next to move the next
node what we can do is we can avoid this
whole traversal with the help of pointer
variable just like head node we can call
this variable tail or even rear let's
call this variable rear for now and also
the variable with storing an address of
head as front in any insertion or
removal will have to update both front
and real now but from now on whenever we
will perform NQ operation we can
directly check where a real node is and
update its address to formulate a new
insertion name this simple addition of
one pointer resolves a problem with the
cost of insertion let's understand this
scenario with the help of an example
previously we were traversing from head
node to the tail node but now as we know
the location of tail node there is no
need for any traversal we can directly
update the address part of real node to
make a link for new node
here the new node with data element 7
will be linked to the previous node and
the rear pointer will also be updated to
point towards the newly inserted node
now the complexity for both the
operation will be big of 1.
which means we can now begin with the
coding implementation of Q using a link
list
so let's dive directly into that
in order to get started with our coding
implementation we'll need to load some
dependencies that are called as header
files I have already included those
header files here so first of all we'll
declare a structure to create nodes for
our linked list and inside the structure
we'll initialize data and address part
so let's get started with creation of
this structure struct
node
now the initialization of data and
address part
and data
struct
node
star
next
Now using this created structure we will
initialize front and rear pointers so
let's create this front and rear pointer
struct
node
star
front
is equal to null
similarly struct
node star
is equal to
none
the Declaration of variables that we
have done here is in global scope the
reason behind that is to make sure that
these variables will be accessible to
all the functions so moving forward
let's work out the primary Q operation
we'll start with NQ operation so let's
create a function for that void
NQ
and inside this function will pass an
argument in X to insert a element
now
inside the enqueue function will take an
integer as an argument in this function
we'll create a new node for purpose of
insertion so let's create that new node
struct
node
star
then
is equal to
struct
node
star
malloc
size of
truck no
so with this size of function we have
allotted the size of address bar as well
as the data part
one more thing I want to tell you guys
is I am using malloc in C here for
dynamic memory allocation if you want to
implement this code using C plus plus
then you can use new operator instead of
malloc the purpose of using malloc here
is to create a node in dynamic memory
now moving ahead
we can start working on two cases of
enqueue operation primarily there won't
be any element inside the queue so for
the first insertion we'll manually set
both front and rear to the address of
this newly created node so to do that
first we'll have to create a if
condition if
front
is equal to equal to null
and add rear
front
is equal to real is equal to 10.
which is nothing but the new created
pointer variable and will return
the control
if this condition fails that means there
are already some elements present inside
our queue so using else condition we can
write another statements real
dot next
is equal to 10.
and Ria
is equal to
10.
basically these two lines of code are
just updating the address part of the
next node along with setting the
temporary data into real nodes data
field
this code will be further clear if I'll
show things moving in simulation so
let's revisit PowerPoint for that
purpose
let's say initially we have an empty
queue so both front and rear will be
null null is only a macro for address
zero at this stage let's say we are
making a call to enqueue function
passing number 2 as an argument now
let's go through the NQ function and see
what will happen first we'll create a
node the data part of this node will be
set as 2 and the address part will
initially set as null let's say we got
this node at address 100 so a variable
name temp will store this address right
now the front and rear both are null so
we'll go inside this if condition and
simply set both front and rear as 100.
after the first NQ operation our queue
will look like this
let's say we are making another call to
enqueue function at this stage passing
number 4 as an argument once again a new
node will be created let's say I got
this new node at address 200 this time
the queue is not empty so in this
function we'll first go to the statement
rear dot next is equal to 10. so we'll
set the next part of this node at
address 100 as the address of a newly
created node which is 200 so we'll build
this link now and now we'll store the
address of this new real node in this
variable name rear so this is how my
queue will look like after the second
enqueue operation
I hope that you guys are clear with the
implementation of NQ operation and the
working of its code let's deal with the
next queue operation named as DQ in our
code editor
now inside this DQ function I'll create
a temporary pointer to the node in which
I'll store the address of the current
front or head node so that we can
directly delete it so the statement I'll
write for that is struct node
star
temp is equal to front
now the first condition that will write
in this DQ function is underflow error
so let's begin with if log f
front
is equal to equal to null
printf
Q
as in empty state
slash n
and return the control to the next
function
otherwise in next case when both front
and rear will be equal will set both
these pointers to the null manually so
to do that we'll insert another if log
if front
is equal to equal to real
front
is equal to real
that's equal to null
this if log will get activated when
there is only one element inside the
queue in all other cases we can simply
make a front point to the next node so
we'll simply do a front is equal to
front dot next so for that we'll write
else block
else
front
is equal to front
Dot next
in all three previous mentioned cases we
are trying to remove elements and that
can only be done by implicit call of
function free so let's call function
free to delete the front node from our
queue so the statement that we'll write
is from free
the temporary variable which is actually
storing the head node address
next we'll work on Peak operation and
for that we'll create a new function
and
Peak
basically the peak function is used to
extract the value of print pointer for
print pointer we will simply check if
the queue is empty if it is empty then
obviously there is no element at front
node to extract but if it is not empty
then we can extract a value from print
pointer so for that we'll create a if
block if
front
is equal to equal to null
which also means the queue is empty
then we'll return
printf
Q
is empty
slash n
otherwise we will return
the data present at front node
now we have implemented all important q
functionalities but we won't be able to
check the state of Q with the help of
these functions so let's formulate one
more function called as print to
visualize our queue so let's define this
function void
print
and set this function will create a
temporary pointer struct
node
staff
temp
is equal to front
we are initializing this temporary
pointer to the front so that we can
Traverse the whole queue elements using
iterator element so moving forward let's
create this iterator element using a
while block so the statement that will
write for that is while
same
is not equal to null
printf
modulus d
comma
Dot
data
and we will say 10 is equal to Temp dot
next
nothing but the traversal of linked list
now we'll also print f
slash n
so that
all elements will be printed in order
with this we have completed the
implementation of print function as well
now let's work on our driver method
called as main function to contemplate
the output of our program
and set this will make call to the
enqueue function NQ
to
and we will print the state of our queue
using print function next we'll make
call NQ
and we will also print the stair using
print function
next we'll make call to NQ 6.
and we'll also print the state of our QR
present stance
now after this we'll dequeue few
elements DQ
print state
next we will enqueue one more 11 and Q8
now that we are done with decoding
implementation of Q using linked list
let's execute the program and visualize
the output
this is the output that we have received
let's compare it with the calls that we
have made in order to judge its
correctness the first call that we made
was nq2 so the print function has
printed two over here
after that we inserted 11 4 and 6 and
our print function has printed the state
after these operations as well next we
deleted the element present at front
pointer which is 2 so after deleting 2
the output that we got is 4 and 6.
finally we inserted one more element to
check if it is getting inserted at the
rear end and that element was it which
is exactly inserted at the rear end of
queue introduction to Priority queue
primarily we will have a look at the
real life example of priority queue to
understand it better a hospital
emergency queue is almost an ideal
example of priority queue when you go to
the hospital you must have observed that
the person who needs immediate medical
attention will be treated first
irrespective of his arrival at the
reception that means treating a person
who is in agonizing pain or in emergency
medical condition is the priority of the
queue of patients priority queue in
computer science also works with same
approach so what exactly is this
priority queue well a priority queue is
an abstract data type that operates
similar to the normal queue except for
the fact every element has certain
priority assigned to it this definition
of priority queue suggests that this
particular type of queue also follows
the same restrictions for insertion and
deletion of data elements the insertion
in the priority queue will only be
achieved at one end and deletion at
another or opposite time
Additionally the priority of data
elements will determine the order of
removal the elements which has higher
priority will leave the Queue at first
and the elements which has lower
priority will definitely leave the Queue
at Large
as a side note I would like to tell you
guys that the priority queue only
supports the elements that are
comparable meaning the data that we are
going to insert into priority queue must
be orderable the compiler should not be
facing any difficulty while comparing
these data elements otherwise the
execution of a priority queue will
definitely fail moving ahead let's have
a look at an example of priority queue
in this priority queue we'll insert 7 to
45 23 and 12 respectively these elements
are not ordered so how the priority
queue is going to store them in order
well at the time of insertion the
priority queue conducts a comparison of
each element with every other element
present inside a queue to store them in
order but as there is no element inside
a queue so the first insertion that is
an element with value 7 will be attained
followed by that the next element will
be inserted in a queue since the newly
inserted element is smaller than that of
previously inserted element we'll swap
their positions in order to maintain
order remember the element with least
value will have a higher order and the
element with greatest value will have a
least priority or order
now we will insert the next element in a
queue that is 45 as 45 is a larger
element than the elements inside the
queue there is no need to shuffle
elements when we make the next insertion
Element 32 will get inserted at index 3.
now this element is smaller than that of
45 so the algorithm will have to swap
the locations of these elements now we
will perform the final insertion into
our queue we'll insert 12 at index 4 now
but as you can see this 11 is smaller
than both the previous elements thus the
algorithm will have to swap their
positions now 45 will reach the end of Q
as it is the element with highest value
and 2 will remain at the front of Q as
it is the least valued 11. as a human we
could see the numbers visually inside
the priority queue and further we can
easily arrange them but how does the
machine know this does it restore all
the elements inside the priority queue
before each insertion no obviously that
would be highly ineffective as there
will be n comparisons for insertion of n
elements leading to time complexity bigo
Up N Square this is an enormous time
complexity which we cannot allow in any
software application we will understand
how the priority queue manages to reduce
this time complexity in upcoming topics
but right now we will contemplate
different properties of a priority queue
that we have learned from previous
example the first property of priority
queue suggests that each element has a
certain priority assigned to it that
priority might depend on value of data
element it can be either larger or
smaller the next property states that
element with higher priority will leave
the Queue at first where the element
with least priority will leave the
priority Queue at last
further if two elements have the same
priority then the element will be
removed from the priority queue based on
their arrival that means the elements
which arrived at first out of the
elements having same priority will be
removed first
now moving ahead we'll deal with the
representation of priority queue using a
linked list as usage of arrays is not an
ideal way to implement priority queue if
we consider array implementation of
priority queue then inserting items into
the sorted array will cost us Big O of N
and in general processing each element
will further cost us Big O of n Square
as discussed previously so in this
tutorial we'll just look into the linked
list representation of priority queue
we will understand the representation of
priority queue with the help of an
example initially let's say there are
three elements inside a link priority
queue and all of them are in order three
being the list element has highest
priority where 43 has the least priority
the purpose of keeping 3 at the head
node is that we want our priority queue
to delete elements according to their
priority
now we want to insert a new node
consisting of data element 2 and as the
data element is smaller than the element
at head node that is 3 so this new node
should be inserted prior to it
this particular scenario of insertion
seems pretty perfect and it does not
cost us more time but what if the
element is significantly larger than all
the nodes in queue for instance let's
say we want to insert 45 as a new
element
in that case primarily it will be
compared with element 2 and as 45 is
larger than 2 our temporary pointer will
move to the next node for comparison
now 45 will be compared with element 3
and again the temporary pointer will be
moved to the next node for comparison
after two comparisons the temporary
pointer has reached element 17 for
performing the next comparison and here
also 45 is larger than 17. so the
temporary pointer will again move
towards the next node
now finally our temporary pointer has
arrived at the tail node consisting of
element 43. again in this case the
element 45 is larger than 43 thus the
new node will be inserted after node
containing data element 43.
from this specific example of insertion
into a priority queue we can clearly see
that there are n comparisons leading to
the time complexity big of n where the
complexity of deletion remains constant
that is big of one
while understanding the representation
of priority queue we came across some
facts that make priority queue
implementation using linked list quite
vulnerable so here we will again try to
recall them the first drawback of
priority queue implementation using
linked list is that it cost us bigger of
n for inserting a new element
further it also cost us big of n for
Peak operation and as memory and time
management is the purpose of data
structure hence we must try to analyze
other implementation strategies that is
why in upcoming slides we'll look into
different approaches to implement a
priority queue
there are three approaches that
Implement a priority queue with
complexity less than bigger pen Square
we have already discussed the link list
so let's also look into other two
approaches binary Heap and binary tree
provides almost similar complexity these
approaches cost us bigger login for
insertion and deletion and big of 1 for
Peak operation but which one of these
operation is most optimal approach to
implement priority queue
well to answer this question we again
need to discuss about memory management
in the case of both these data structure
you guys know that binary Heap data
structure is implemented using arrays
and since it utilizes array there is
always a better locality of reference as
well as operations become more cache
event
the binary search tree uses pointer to
implement front and rear node which
definitely takes up more space in memory
due to that building a cell balancing
BST cost us bigger of n log n where
binary Heap just cost us big of n
these facts clarify that the binary Heap
is the base data structure to implement
the priority queue
now you must be thinking about what
exactly the Heap is and how does it work
so moving forward we'll look into the
definition of Heap and its properties
basically a heap is a tree based data
structure that satisfies the Heap
invariant or in simpler words he
property the Heap invariant states that
if a is a parent node of B then a is
ordered with respect to B for all nodes
A and B in he what that means is the
value of parent node is always greater
than or equal to the value of child node
in the Heat or other way around the
value of parent node is less than or
equal to the value of child node for all
nodes in a heap
further there are two types of Heap
named as Max Heap and minimum Heap first
we will look into maxi the max Heap is
Heap in which value of parent node is
greater than the value of child node
for this particular example of Max Heap
you can see that the root node is the
biggest element in tree and each child
node is smaller than its parent node
the next type of Heap is minimum heat
the mean Heap is Heap in which the value
of parent node is less than the value of
child node
in this specific example you can observe
that each child node is larger than its
parent node and the element at the root
node is smallest element of the Heat
both the structures that we have
discussed are binary Heats as every node
has only two children in upcoming slides
we'll discuss some complex structures of
Heap data structure to better understand
how we can judge if a tree-like
structure is Heap or not
okay so you can see a tree like
structure on your screen and we are
supposed to check whether if it is a
valid Heap data structure or not but
actually here I would like you all to
give it a try by yourself you can also
pause this video if you want but here I
will provide you with a short moment to
inspect this structure
all right I can clearly say that this is
not a valid Heap data structure as you
can observe the highlighted part is
violating the Heap invariant
moving forward let's analyze another
tree like data structure to consider if
it is a valid Heap or not
well yes this is a valid Heap because
even though this one is strangely
structured we are free to move around
the visual representation of nodes to
make it organized now you all must be
thinking how we can do that well we'll
understand that scenario in upcoming
slides
now
how about this one is this a valid Heap
no right this is not a valid Heap this
structure is not even a tree as it forms
a closed cycle and every Heap must be a
tree so it's pretty clear that this is
not a valid Heap now what about this one
is this a valid Heap
yes this is a valid Heap as it satisfies
the Heap invariant that all the child
nodes must be greater than or equal to
or smaller than or equal to its parent
node
now this is the last structure that we
are going to check if it is a valid Heap
or not
what you guys think
is this a valid Heap
well I think it's pretty clear that this
is not a valid Heap but it can be
converted into a heap by making a one
small change now if we make 6 as our
root node then this structure will get
converted into a maxi which is
absolutely a valid Heat
I hope you all are clear with the Heap
invariant and how to judge if a given
tree is a valid Heap or not
now moving ahead we'll discuss the
different types of priority queue
basically there are two types of
priority queue based on the priority of
elements if the element with smallest
value has highest priority then that
priority queue is called as Min priority
queue and if element with higher value
has the highest priority then that
priority queue is known as Max priority
queue furthermore it's vividly clear
that the mean priority queue can be
implemented with a minimum Heap where
the max priority queue can be
implemented using maximum Heap moving
ahead will deal with the operations in
priority queue considering the Heap as
implementation strategy
the common operations that we can
perform on priority queue are insertion
deletion and Peak but there is one more
hidden additional operation that gets
performed during these operations that
operation is called as hipify hepify
manages the priority of data elements in
a heap by shuffling the data elements
after new insertion or deletion
first of all we will understand how
insertion in priority queue happens with
the help of an example in this example
we are inserting a new data element that
is 43.
but due to disinsertion the structure
disobeys the priority queue invariant
that the parent node of the max priority
queue must be greater than its child
node now the hippify operation solves
this problem by rearranging data
Elements by carrying out the comparison
in this particular case 43 becomes the
parent node where 40 becomes the China
the next up is deletion as we know the
highest priority element will be the
first to leave the priority queue and
further it is stored at the root node of
a maxi so definitely the element present
at the root node will get removed
but due to this operation the order of
priority queue gets affected however the
hipify operation comes to the rescue it
reshuffles the elements of the priority
queue to rearrange them in order
the next operation that we are going to
discover is peak the peak operation
simply Returns the element present at
root node without removing it and it is
easily accessible thus the time
complexity of this operation is Big of
one
I hope you all are clear with the
operations that can be performed on
priority queue moving forward we'll try
to implement them with the help of
minimum Heat
as discussed earlier while implementing
a heap data structure we know that all
the elements will get stored in an array
and we don't have any pointers pointing
to either child or parent nodes so how
exactly does the Heap data structure
remember nodes like parent nodes and its
left or right nodes well if you have
learned binary trees then you must know
the formulas present on your screen
these formulas determines the left child
right child or even the parent node of
any binary tool
let's understand how this phenomenon
works with the help of an example we'll
begin with index 0. if we enter 0 in
this arithmetic expression then we will
get 1 and 2 as output that means the
element at index 1 will be the left
child and element at index 2 will be the
right side and tree structure will look
like this
now moving ahead let's take an example
of index 1 for index 1 the left child
will be at index 3 and the right child
will be at index 4.
similarly for index 2 the left child
will be at index 5 where the right child
will be at index 6. using these formulas
we'll be implementing HiFi and primary
queue operations so note them down for
further reference
now moving further we will visit code
Editor to implement priority queue data
structure using C programming language
previously I mentioned that Heap is
implemented using arrays so to begin
with Heap implementation primarily we
will create a structure consisting of
different variables or objects needed to
implement Heap data structure so let's
create a structure
struck he
consists in size
in count variable
and
star
Heap array
which is a dynamic array that we are
creating here
and next we'll also declare a pointer to
Heap structure along with size and count
variable in a global scope so let's do
that end
star here
comma size
comma
count
we'll create one more variable and
initial
underscore size to represent the initial
size of our priority queue and let's
assign it value 4 for now
okay
now it's time to allocate memory to our
Heap array for this purpose we'll create
a new function called Heap underscore
init so let's create this function void
Heap underscore init
and inside it will pass an argument
struct
Heap
star
h
which is a reference of this structure
that we created previously
okay
in this function let's initialize the
variables that we have created inside
this Heap structure
so for that we'll initialize h
Arrow operator
count
is equal to 0.
similarly
h
Arrow operator
size
is equal to
initial underscore size
and
h
foreign
is equal to
n
star
malloc
size of
end
star 4.
this statement is just allocating four
integer variables to our Heap array
basically our Heap array is dynamic data
structure that's why we have to provide
it with dynamic memory using malloc if
you are using C plus plus programming
language to implement this data
structure then you can use new instead
of malloc
moving forward
now we'll work on our condition f
dot h
Arrow operator
allocates memory to Heap array then
printf
error while
allocating
the memory
and
that slash on
next we will write exit command
okay
with this we have successfully
implemented our Heap init function now
moving ahead let's Implement hipify
function to move the nodes for that
we'll create a hipify function void
Max underscore
apify
end
star
data
and
log
count
so all these are required variables to
implement this hepify function that we
have passed in argument for this Maxi P5
function now let's create few more
variables that we need in left
comma right
comma largest
comma 10.
now as discussed earlier left
will be equal to 2
star
location
in Array Plus 1.
and
write
will be equal to
left
plus one
now let's
say largest is equal to NOC
and
will work on conditions now f
left
it's greater than or equal to count
and and
data
left
it's greater than
data
largest
that it's
the location we have stored in largest
variable
then
largest is equal to
left
with this block what we are doing is we
are checking if the element at location
left is greater than the element at
recent position and the value at left is
also greater than the value of recent
location if these conditions are 2 then
we will set the recent location as left
and here we are getting signal that
there is semicolon missing over here so
we'll add it
okay now let's work on next condition
now we will check the value at right
position if the recent location is
greater than the right and the value at
right is greater than the largest value
then element at largest will be set to
right so for that we'll write condition
f
right
it's
count
and end
data
write
it's greater than
data
largest
then largest
is equal to right
activity
otherwise if
largest
it's not equal to
location
then
we will store
the data present at location in
temporary variable
and
data Loc
is equal to data
largest
this is a swapping operation that we are
carrying out here and next data
largest
is equal to
10.
and now we'll make recursive call to our
heifer function Max underscore
if if I
data comma largest
comma count
with this we have successfully completed
our heapify function
now we will work on insertion operation
on priority queue let's call this
function hip underscore push
because we are treating this structure
as Heap right so and if insertion is
called as push operation so we'll call
it
void
keep underscore push and will pass
arguments
struct
heaps star
Edge
and
value
and inside this function will create few
more variables and index
and parent
if you guys remember the initial size
that we have allocated to our array is
16 bytes
you can verify with this statement here
that we are providing 16 byte size to
our Heap array
but what if you want to insert elements
more than 4 then what we'll do when for
that we'll need to increase the size of
our Heap array so we'll do that here
for this resize we'll create if
condition
f h
Dot
count
it's equal to equal to H
Dot
sides
then
h
dot size
plus equal to
1.
and H
Dot
Heap array
is equal to
real lock
Edge
Dot
Heap array
size of
end
star
h
Dot
slides
basically we are using the real lock
function in C to extend the dynamic
memory space for our Heap array and in
order to increase the size we have to
increment the size variable first so
that's what we have done in this
statement here and now once done with
this we'll check if our dynamic memory
is getting allocated or not so for that
we'll add one more if condition inside
this if block so it can be called as
nested if if you guys want
Dot
Heap array
then
exit
minus 1.
now we'll move out of this a block
and we will set index variable
to
h
Dot
count
plus plus
basically we are iterating with help of
index variable here
so next we'll add four condition
for Loop
index
to index
is equal to parent
and then set this condition
will make parent node is equal to
index
minus 1
by
this is nothing but the formula that we
have discussed in previous part
now
we'll add one more condition inside this
for Loop if
h
Dot
keep array
parent
it's greater than or equal to
value
then we will break this for Loop
otherwise
H Dot
Heap array
index
will be equal to
Edge
Dot Heap array
parent
now we'll move outside this for Loop and
we'll add one more condition of
insertion that is H
Dot Heap array
and add
position index
we will add
the value provided by
user using argument to Heap push
function
okay with this we have successfully
created our Heap push function now we
will move towards the next function that
adds Heap underscore delete for that
we'll create new function keep
underscore delete
and let's make this function
integer
and we'll pass
truth
keep
star
H as an argument
we will create one more variable
temp
is equal to
H Arrow operator
keep array
and inside this will pass a negating
index that means we are using this
temporary variable to Traverse through
all list of elements so for that we'll
write dot dot minus minus
h
Arrow operator count which will
decrease count one by one
now next we'll add condition f
h
Arrow operator
count
it's greater than or equal to
h
Arrow operator
size
Plus
and and
h
Arrow operator
size
it's also greater than the initial
underscore
size okay
then what we will do is we will
set
size
to negate itself
by 1 for each iteration and then
we will
add H Arrow operator
Heap array
is equal to realock
h
Dot
sheep array
comma
size of
end
star
H Arrow operator
and sides
sorry
sides
and semicolon
so basically what we are doing here is
we are checking if count is smaller than
the size of heat plus 2 and at the
dynamic size of Q is also larger than
initialized size that is 4 then what we
are doing is we are reducing the size
for deleting an element using this
statement and in next statement we are
reallocating that deleted space
so this is how this if block works
now moving forward we'll add condition
to check if memory is getting located or
not so that will write condition if
not h
Arrow operator
Heap array
then
what we'll do is exit
with
minus 1.
okay now let's move out of this bit
block
and now
we will
set this remote variable to
Edge Arrow operator
Heap array
and index 0.
so if you guys remember 0 is the index
of the highest element in our maximum
Heat
what I mean here is the element with
highest value is stored at index 0 for
maxi now moving forward to delete this
element what we'll do is we will set h
Dot
Heap array
and index 0
is equal to
temporary variable
or pointer that we have created
previously
and
next what we'll do is we'll call Max
underscore ap5 function
to rearrange the structure of our
priority queue which has been shuffled
due to this delete operation now for
that we'll
pass arguments are Heap structure that
is Heap array
and next
the index which was removed and the
count
variable
and we'll return the remove element
okay with this we have successfully
implemented our delete function
now to understand the order of deletion
in priority queue we will Implement one
more function called as mtpq so let's
create this function
and in this function we'll pass the
reference of Heap structure in order to
operate on it so let's pass
structure
he
da
h
and insert this function
we will create a while loop
H Dot
[Music]
count
as not equal to
zero
then printf
modulus d
and
recursive call to Heap delete
function
and which will pass h
now we are done with this mtpq function
further you will create one more
function to visualize our priority queue
let's call this function void Heap
underscore display
and then set this will pass
structure Heap
star
h
and now
we will create one iterator element
and
using that iterator element will create
for loop I is equal to 0 to I
it's greater than
Arrow operator count
plus plus I
and then set this for Loop we will print
the elements present in our queue using
this moment
modulus d
and we'll call
Heap
array but for that we'll need to call
structure as well
if array and will pass this iterator
variable into it
okay and then next we'll get outside
this for Loop and will print as
to the next line using slash n
okay
now we have implemented all the required
function for our priority queue moving
forward will work on our driver function
that is main method to contemplate the
result of our program so for that we'll
First Call struct
keep Edge
then we'll call init function to create
Heap structure so Heap in it and will
pass
the address of h
next we will call
Heap
underscore push function to insert
element
and H
comma 1.
next
I'll copy this
part
with paste it to insert another element
now we'll insert 5 here
next
and we'll pause three
next we'll insert element seven
next will
insert element nine
and after this we'll insert element 8.
okay so now let's display the elements
inside our key using Heap underscore
display function
and let's press and H object
to print it and
okay
we'll call
empty PQ function
empty
p q
plus h
and after deleting all elements it will
return the state of our Heap array again
or our priority queue so finally we'll
add return 0 statement
and now our code is ready so let's
compile it and check it if it works fine
or not
so we are getting four errors here guys
so we'll need to resolve them first
we'll need to check line number 82.
so for 82
okay here we haven't added semicolon
so I think this should be fine now still
we have two errors
before I
teach there
so let's recompile it and check it if it
is working fine now
so we have received our output now now
if you look at our output our output is
printing elements nine seven eight one
five and three and deletion of elements
is also happening according to their
order so 9 is getting deleted first
after eight seven five three and one
so that means our elements are getting
removed in proper order further we can
say that our program for priority queue
implementation works fine now if you
guys are worried about this program then
not to worry we have you covered you can
mention your email IDs in comment box
below and we will send it over to you
remember guys we can make comments
private to protect all your data so you
can fearlessly put all your email IDs in
comment box below
now we will discuss applications of
priority queue to understand its
importance
the first application that we are going
to discuss is use of priority queue in
Google Maps you must have used Google
Maps several times to navigate from one
city to another or from your location to
nearest desired location have you ever
wondered how Google Maps managed to do
that how does it provide an optimal path
to reach your location
algorithm implemented in Google Maps
actually manages to do that by gaining
access to all possible Parts this
algorithm uses the priority queue to
maintain all the parts in order let's
understand how it works in detail
now when you provide the location of
place you want to reach via your mobile
device Google Maps feeds the data of all
possible path to digestra's algorithm
those paths or Road are stored in
minimum priority queue considering the
distance as parameter for priority
assignment and we have learned that the
minimum priority queue maintains the
lowest value at the front or root node
this is how the priority queue helps
Google map to search for an ideal path
for reaching destination location
the next application that we are going
to discuss is data compression in WinZip
or gzip these applications use Huffman
encoding algorithm to reduce the size of
files Huffman coding is a lossless data
compression algorithm and in this
algorithm a variable link code is
assigned to input different characters
the code link is related to how grequit
characters are used most recurring
characters have the smallest course and
longer course are for the least frequent
characters this is how the generated
codes will maintain the complete data
while utilizing less memory space
let's understand how this process works
with the help of an example let's say
our text file contains these random
characters
the Huffman encoding algorithm creates
scores for each character based on its
number of occurrences for instance the
frequency of character a is more
prominent than b and character C has
less frequency so the length of code a
is smaller than b and length of code B
will be smaller than C
now according to the amount of generated
code the priority queue will determine
the priority of characters and will
store them these codes takes less size
than the actual characters in memory
space and due to the mapping of
occurrences data does not get lost
I hope now you guys understand why the
priority queue is stated as an abstract
data structure itself and why it is the
better version of Q data structure what
is DQ
DQ is an abbreviation for double ended
queue and as the term double ended queue
suggests it is a type of queue with some
Advanced features at both of its aims
but previously we have learned that the
basic queue data structure must perform
insertion from one of its n and deletion
from another or opposite end
so what new limitation or feature does
this particular type of queue brings
well the DQ extends the concept of a
linear queue by implementing insertion
and deletion at both of its nodes by
that what I mean is the DQ data
structure is acquainted with the
possibility to insert and delete new
elements at any node that is why DQ is
concerned as more generalized version of
Q data structure
now moving ahead we shall understand the
Key properties of DQ
the first property of DQ states that the
DQ can use the Lipo principle for
inserting or removing elements the last
in first or principle is used while
implementing stack data structure and
according to this principle the queue
elements must be inserted from one end
and should also be removed from the same
end
for instance we are storing some
elements inside this queue structure
which is performing both insertion and
deletion from one end
however when deletion Begins the element
inserted at last will be removed first
whereas the element stored at first will
get removed at the end this property
clears that the DQ can inherit all the
properties of Stack data structure
the next property of DQ states that the
DQ can use the FIFA principle for
performing both insertion and deletion
operations that means the element which
enters inside the Q at beginning will
also leave the Q at first
further the element which entered at
last can leave the Queue at last both of
these properties displays the uniqueness
of this particular type of queue data
structure now in upcoming slides we will
understand different types of the D Cube
the first type of DQ we have is termed
as input restricted queue this
terminology itself suggests that this
particular type of DQ will have some
restrictions while performing enqueue or
insertion operation
in this type of DQ the insertion can
only be performed from one end where
deletion can be performed at both of its
ends the representation of DQ shown
below explains how the operations in
this type of DQ will get accomplished
the next type of DQ is output restricted
DQ this term makes clear that this type
of queue will have some restrictions
while performing deletion operations
in this specific type of queue the
removal of elements can only be
performed from one end where the
insertion can be performed at both of
its ends this particular structure of a
queue explains how the different
operations will take place in this type
of DQ
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer based on
the properties of DQ that we have
discussed till now which of the
following data structure will be more
ideal for implementing DQ in data
structure
what I mean by ideal is the time and
space complexity for implementation
strategy that you decide should be
minimum the options that we have are
circular array singly linked list and
doubly linked list
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right so guys
do leave your answers to this question
in comment section Below in a week's
time we'll be announcing the right
answer and you all can check it out
on that note let's dive further and
understand the representation of DQ
using circular queue and yes circular
queue is one of the answers for previous
questions we'll understand why it is
based in upcoming slides but please
check the complexity analysis of all the
two strategies to decide your answer for
the previous question as multiple
answers can be accurate for that
question
now let's understand what a circular
queue is well a circular queue is
nothing but the extended notion of
linear Q as it follows the first in
first out principle with the exception
that the last position of this
particular queue is connected to its
first position making a circular link
this circular link is responsible for
naming of this queue as circular queue
or ring buffer let's understand how a
circular queue operates with the help of
simulation this is the illustration of a
circular queue having size 5 as the
position of rear pointer keeps
increasing a new element will be
inserted in this queue until the rear
pointer reaches the end of queue
but what if we perform DQ operation now
if we perform the deletion then the
empty space will get created at front of
queue however this space can further be
utilized in this particular type of
queue by making circular incrementation
of rear pointer or circular link
so if we increment the rear pointer from
its index 5 to index 0 we can utilize
empty space by making new insertions
using this feature of circular queue we
can Implement both insertion and
deletion at both the ends of Q let's
understand how we can do that in
upcoming slides
the first type of insertion is a pretty
ordinary one in this insertion will
increment the position of rear pointer
to insert a new element the arrow shown
in blue is rear pointer and the arrow
shown in Orange is the front pointer so
as you can see once we increment the
rear pointer new elements get inserted
this is how the insertion using rear
node happens
now what if we want to perform insertion
using front end in order to perform the
insertion using front node we'll have to
make front pointer reach to the end of
queue the only possible way to achieve
that is to set front pointer equal to
Max size -1 manually
this command will allow a front pointer
to reach the end of queue for performing
insertion and for further insertions
we'll just have to decrement the front
pointer location for inserting new
elements this is all about insertion now
that we have implemented insertion from
both ends let's move on to the deletion
operation
primarily we'll look into the deletion
using front node in order to delete
elements using front node we'll have to
increment the front pointer until it
reaches the end of queue and once it
reaches the max size we'll use circular
incrementation to bring the front
pointer to the beginning of queue while
performing these incrementation
meanwhile the elements will be removed
from the queue
next up is deletion using rear air for
performing deletion using a rear pointer
we'll have to decrement its location
once we decrement the rear pointer
location the element will get removed
from the queue
now moving ahead we'll look into the
different operations that can be
performed on a double ended queue
basically there are four primary
operations in the DQ which we have
already understood in the representation
of DQ using circular queue these
operations are insertion and deletion at
the front and insertion and deletion at
the rear
Additionally the circular queue
implementation of DQ cost us bigger of 1
which is the most optimal complexity
that we can hope for having said that
let's dive into the implementation of
these operations using a circular queue
we'll Implement a double ended queue
using circular queue in order to do that
we'll use C programming language and one
dimensional arrays so without wasting
any time further let's move to the code
editor
now in order to get started with
implementation of DQ we'll have to
create array and pointer variables so
let's do that
and we'll name this array as DQ
and will provide 100 as initial size
next we'll create pointers
and rear
is equal to minus 1.
now we'll also Define the maximum size
for our queue using Define call
size as 5.
after done with this initialization
process we'll start working on insertion
from front mode we'll declare a function
named as void front insert so let's do
that void
front
underscore insert
and insert this function will pass an
argument into Z to insert an element
now while performing insertion we should
always check if the queue is full or not
because if it is full then the insertion
won't be possible so for that we'll
write condition if
front
is equal to equal to zero
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to size minus 1
inside
and braces
or
front
is equal to equal to Ria
plus 1
printf
TQ
as full
insertion
not possible
okay
otherwise if both the front and rear
node are pointing to null memory index
or minus 1 will manually set up front
pointer to index 0 to make the first
insertion into the queue and we will
insert the element at new location or
index 0 where the front pointer is
pointing so for that what we'll do is
we'll write another condition with LC
block else if
front
is equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
is equal to equal to -1
then
make front is equal to real is equal to
zero
and
DQ
front
is equal to Z
now if we want to insert the element at
the last node of Q then we need to set
front pointer to the max size minus 1
location to do that we'll write this
condition else
if
front
is equal to equal to 0
then
front
is equal to size minus 1
and DQ
front
is equal to Z
if all these above mentioned conditions
fail then the front pointer is already
at the last part of Q and it just need
to decrement its location for inserting
element in empty spaces as discussed
previously so to do that we'll write one
more condition using else block so let's
do that
else
front
is equal to front
minus 1.
and DQ
front
is equal to Z
now we have successfully implemented a
front insert function so let's move
forward and work on another function
that is called as void
real
underscore insert
and will pass
Z as an argument to insert an element
now as done previously we will first
check if our queue is full or not so
let's do that using IF condition if
front
is equal to equal to 0
and and
Ria
is equal to equal to size minus 1
inside braces
or
front
is equal to equal
to equal to
Ria
plus 1
then
printf
DQ
is full
next if there is no element in an array
we'll manually set the rear pointer to
index 0 for new insertion so for that
we'll write condition else f
front
it's equal to equal to -1
and and real
then
set real
it's equal to zero
and insert DQ
Ria
is equal to Z
otherwise if real pointer is already at
the end of Q then we will bring it to
the beginning of Q so for that we'll
write condition else if
real
it's equal to equal to size
minus 1
then
being real
to index 0.
and DQ
area
is equal to Z
if all these mentioned conditions fail
then what we'll do is we'll write else
condition and we'll simply increment our
rear pointer to make an insertion so for
that what we'll do is we'll create else
block and we're inside it we will do
real plus plus
and we will set DQ real
is equal to C
with this we have successfully
implemented void rear insert function so
now let's move into deletion functions
first we'll create void front DQ
function void front
underscore TQ
and there is no need for any argument
for this function
to begin with this function first we'll
have to check if DQ is empty because we
cannot delete elements if there is no
element to delete so for that we'll
write F condition f
front
it's equal to equal to minus 1.
and and
rear
is equal to equal to -1
then
printf
there is no element
to
delete
inside this DQ
in the next condition we'll check if
there is only one element inside the TQ
if there is only one element then we
will set both front and rear to -1
manually for that what we'll do is we'll
create else if condition
else if front is equal to equal to Ria
printf
let's slash in to take this to the next
slide
the
deleted
element
from
the front is
modulus d
comma
DQ
front
and we will set front is equal to minus
similarly Ria
is equal to minus 1.
now if both these above mentioned
conditions fail then we will delete the
element from our front node the first
removal will be in a case when the front
pointer is at the end of Q so for that
we'll write condition else f
front
it's at end of queue that its size
minus 1.
and what we'll do is
we will print f
slash n
the deleted
element
from the front
Edge
modulus day
comma DQ
front
comma
and another condition will be when the
front pointer is at the beginning
section of a cube for that we'll write
else condition
printf
slash n
the deleted
element
from
the front edge
modulus d
comma DQ
front
with this we have successfully
implemented our front DQ function now
let's move towards next function that is
deletion from the rear end for that
we'll create new function name void DQ
underscore real
and this function also does not need any
argument so next what we'll do is we'll
create condition to check if the queue
is empty or not
so
if front
it's equal to equal to -1
and and
real it's equal to equal to -1
then
printf
print as
slash n
there is no element
to delete
inside the queue
now let's move to the next condition
in next condition we'll write else f
ont
equal to equal to Ria
then
printf
some statement
and
set front is equal to
-1 along with real is equal to
-1
and that statement will be
the
deleted
element
from
the DQ
using
rear node adds modulus t
comma
DQ
area
now if both these above mentioned
conditions fail then we'll have to
delete element from our real node the
first removal will be in a case when Ria
is at the beginning portion of a queue
for that let's write a condition
else if
real
it's equal to equal to 0 that is at the
beginning part of Q then
printf
some statement
and
rear
is equal to size minus 1 that is setting
it to the max size of cube and the
statement that we will return is
backslash n
the deleted
element
from
the Ria
node
as modulus d
comma DQ
rear
and other cases we'll just have to
decrement the size of rear pointer and
delete the element so for that we'll
write else condition
printf some statement
and
set rear
is equal to real
minus 1 that is decrementing the size of
rear pointer and the statement that will
write as backslash n
the deleted
element
from
the area node
adds modulus d
and comma
DQ
area
well here is one spelling mistake so
let's remove it
okay
so with this we have successfully
implemented our void DQ real function
now we will Implement one more function
to display the state of our
TQ the name of that function will be
void
display
and this function also does not need any
argument
so we'll begin with implementation of
this function for this we'll create an
iterator element and we'll set it to the
front
pointer
and we'll print f
backslash n
elements
inside
the dub double
ended queue
r
next line
will enter into while loop to print
those element
I
not equal to
Ria
printf
modulus d
comma
DQ
I
and will increase the value of I by
I plus 1
modulus
sides
and
outside this while loop we will print f
modulus d
Q
Ria
okay
with this we have implemented all the
required functionalities for our DQ so
let's work on driver method that is main
function in order to check the output of
a program so let's work on this main
function first we will insert
few elements into a queue so I will
insert first element using front insert
next let's insert one more element from
front node
using function front insert and this
element will be 23.
next we will insert elements using real
node
underscore insert
and we'll pass 17 now
next we'll insert
and
we'll insert one more element using this
real node only
insert
7.
now we will display
the state of a queue after performing
all these operations
and next we will DQ
fill elements so for that we'll use
front DQ function
and next
we will DQ
from real node
so DQ here
and after performing deletion operations
we will also display the state of our
queue so let's call display once again
and let's add one more command return
zero
okay so with this we have successfully
implemented our program for DQ
implementation so let's run it and check
if it is working fine or not
okay so we are getting output here but
uh display function is printing output
in weird manner so let's work it out
so all we have to do is we'll have to
add space before modulus T here and here
as well so once done with this let's
recompile our code
okay so now our output is clear so let's
check if it is
perfect or not
so
the first insertion that we made was -5
second was 23 from the front end so 5
should be getting inserted before 23 so
-5 is getting inserted before 23 but as
we are inserting it using front pointer
so 23 is remaining at the front now
after these two insertions we are
performing insertions using rear pointer
the first rear insertion was 17 then 12
then 47 and these elements are getting
inserted
so let me show you how they are getting
inserted in exact same order
so
look here so elements inside the double
ended QR 23 minus 5 17 12 and 47 that
means the insertion is in right order
after that we deleted the 11 from front
node so the front node is at 23 so 23 is
getting deleted after that we deleted
the element using rear node so 47 is
getting deleted from the rear node
we are still getting 23 here that means
the TQ function is incomplete so we'll
have to change it so let's go to the DQ
function
and I guess it was from front end so
we'll need to change code for our front
DQ so
okay
so in this case we haven't brought our
Trend pointer to index 0 so let's do
that here and once we do this let's
recompile our code again
okay so now you can see that the 23 is
getting deleted
with this we have successfully
implemented our DQ function
now let's move back to the PowerPoint
and understand few applications of DQ
the first application that we are going
to discuss in detail is palindrome
Checker you all must have heard about
the term palindrome the palindrome is a
specific word or number which reads the
same backward as forward for example the
word Rada it reached the same from both
ends so using the DQ we can implement
the palindrome Checker program with
complexity big of one the string which
you need to check will be inserted into
a DQ and after that it will read from
both sides if the reading is the same
then that string will be considered as
palindrome
the next application of DQ is its use in
multiprocessor scheduling but what
precisely is multiprocessor scheduling
and why do we need it well the system
implemented in the old days use single
processor scheduling to manage the
Computing processes
when multiple processes need to be
executed by a single core or CPU then
the process take more time to implement
and thus the system lacks computing
power
but the multiprocessor scheduling
implemented in modern computers resolves
that problem using a double-ended queue
suppose we have three processors in our
system and each processor has some
processes to execute each processor
maintains a DQ that contains threads
that are ready to execute the processor
executes a process and if a process
creates a child process then that
process will be inserted at the front of
the DQ of parent process suppose the
processor P2 has completed the execution
of all its threads then it steals the
thread from the rear end of processor P1
and adds it to the front end of the
processor P2 the processor P2 will take
the thread from Front End therefore the
deletion takes from both dates
this is also known as a still algorithm
in process scheduling in this session we
will learn about stacks and queues in
data structures
what is a stack
so to define stack in a more generalized
way we can consider stack as a linear
data structure that follows lifo order
or lost in first out order or another
way of putting it down is first come
lost out order
so some of the basic operations that can
be performed on stack are insertion and
deletion and that can be done only at
the end which is called as the top of
the stack
now let us understand the basic
operations on stack so the three
fundamental operations that can be
applied onto a data structure like stack
are push pop and Peak so the push
operation involves inserting a new
element from the top of the stack the
pop operation involves removing the
element from the top of the stack and
finally the peak operation which Returns
the topmost element from the stack
without removing the element from the
stack
now we shall go through some generalized
examples of Stack
so some of the generalized examples of
Stack are you can see a stack of books
here and a stack of utensils stack of
coins and stack of dollars or bills
now let
practical exam
stack in data structures we shall be
using C programming language for this
particular example
so you can see that on my screen I have
an example for stack data structure
don't worry about the code this code
will be attached in the description box
below and you can always have access to
it and you can run the same code in your
personal system so that you have a
deeper and better understanding of the
program now let's quickly run this
program
foreign
you can see the program is getting
executed now
so you can see that the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are being inserted into this stack
now the elements are a b and finally the
elements are popped back again that is b
a and the last element that is popped
away from the stack is a and you can see
that the stack is currently empty so top
is pointing to -1 now with that let's
get back to the presentation again
now let us understand some of the
applications of Stack so one of the
applications of Stack is function call
or recursion the recursive function call
is also known as the called stack
whenever a function is called then the
function goes to the top of the stack
now another important application of
Stack is expression conversion there are
three types of notations that is prefix
notation and fix notation and post fix
notation so these particular notations
can be taken care by using Stacks in
real time
now the next one is checking parenthesis
stack is used to check if the given
parenthesis are balanced or not
sometimes if you forget to add a
parenthesis then the compiler will
through an error so using stack this can
be found if there are balanced
parentheses used in your program or not
balanced parenthesis means opening and
closing brackets are of the same type
that means if you have two open flower
brackets then you need to have two
closed flower brackets it should not be
an equal it should be completely equal
to complete the code segment now another
application of Stack is expression
evaluation stack can be used to evaluate
the Expressions as you can see here we
have an expression that is 6 plus 2 Star
3 minus 12 divided by 4. now this
particular expression will be evaluated
based on the presidency table so the
stack is used to check the Precedence
and then the expression gets evaluated
into the result which is 21 right over
here
now another application is the Tower of
Hanoi Tower of Hanoi is a mathematical
puzzle which consists of three rows and
N number of disks of different diameters
all this are placed on one rod one over
the other and in ascending order size
similarly into a cone shaped Tower
now we will enter into the next segment
where we will discuss about cues so what
exactly is the queue a queue is a linear
data structure that follows the fifo
order that is the first and first out
whereas stack followed first in last out
so this is one of the fundamental
difference between stacks and queues so
we'll be discussing those in the next
section for now let's continue with the
operations on Queue the queue is an
ordered list in which insertion is done
at one end that is called rare and
relation is done at another end which is
called front the operations on QR and
queue operation that adds a new item to
the queue if the queue is complete then
there is an overflow condition DQ
operation is the operation which deletes
an item from the queue and if the queue
is empty then there is an underflow
condition thrown as an exception
now let us understand some of the basic
examples of queue you can consider the
patients at Hospital registration and
you can also consider an example of
customers making use of ATM
now let us understand the types of queue
so there are basically three types of
queues those are circular queues doubly
ended queues and priority queues
now let us understand the circular queue
in a circular queue the last element
points to the first element to form a
circular link circular queue is also
known as ring buffer insertion is done
at the rear and deletion is done at the
front as discussed before
now we will go through the doubly ended
queue in doubly ended queue both
insertion and deletion can be done at
both rear and front of the queue
now the last one the priority queue in
the priority queue the nodes have same
predefined priority insertion can be
done as the arrival of the nodes node
having the least priority will be the
first node removed from the queue now we
will go through a general practical
example of queues and then we will go
through the applications of queues now
on my screen you can see an example for
cues don't worry about the code this
code will be attached in the description
box below and you can always have access
to it and learn executing this on your
own system so without further Ado let's
start to execute this code
so you can see that the code got
successfully executed and the terminal
is asking for us to give an operation so
the first one is to insert an element
into the queue second one is to delete
an element and the third one is to
display the elements in the queue and
the fourth one is the quote let's insert
so now let us insert an element in PQ
that is 10.
now let's try to display the elements in
the queue for that I need to select the
option number three
and there you go the queue has element
number 10. now let's try to delete that
element so that we might have to choose
the second option
so you can see that the element got
deleted from the queue and the element
deleted from the queue is 10 and you
have another choice now so let's try to
quit it now so that I need to select the
option 4 because we have seen how to
insert a view and delete the element
let's not make further delay and let's
quickly enter into the next part of our
session that is the application of
queues so the first application of Q is
breath first search breath first search
or VFS traverses a graph in a breadth
what direction and uses a queue to
remember the next node to start as such
the second application is level order
traversal entry level order traversal
processes all the nodes of a tree by
depth first the root then the children
of the source
next one is first come first serve CPU
scheduling first come first serve fcfs
is an operating system algorithm that
works on queued requests and implements
them according to their arrival
now the Fibonacci Fibonacci Heap is a
data structure that implements priority
queue operations consisting of the
collection of Heap order trees
now our last segment that is the
comparison between stack and queue
so at first both stack and queue are
linear data structures and stack
followers last in first out whereas Q
follows first in and first out and when
you are considering stack the insertion
takes place at the top and deletion
takes place from the top as well
whereas when it comes to stack the
insertion starts from rare but deletion
or elimination of the element from the
queue starts from the front
in Stacks the insert operation is called
as push
and deletion process is called as Pop
in queues the insertion is called as NQ
and deletion is called as DQ
Instax we mainly maintain one pointer to
access the list that is called top which
always points to the last element
present in the list in queues we
maintain two different pointers the
first one is the front pointer which
always points to the front element or
the first element inserted in the list
and the next one is the rare pointer
which always points to the rare or the
last element inserted into the list
stack is used in solving problems that
work on recursion whereas Q is used in
solving problems having sequential
processing so these are the fundamental
differences between stacks and queues in
this session we will learn about linear
social algorithm its complete logic and
how to program and implement it in real
time now let us try to understand what
exactly is searching
searching in data structure refers to
the process of finding the desired
element in the set of items the selected
item is called the target element any
data structure such as an array linked
list tree or graph can be used for
searching a set of elements in data
structures searching can be categorized
into two types first type is the
sequential search in which we check the
elements in a detail list or an array
one by one
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two ways the first type
is a sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
an example for sequential search is
linear search now let us learn about the
next type of searching approach the next
type of searching approach is the
interval search approach interval search
divides the search in half by repeatedly
targeting the center of the data set the
binary search algorithm can be an
example for Interval search we will go
over the binary search algorithm in
detail in our upcoming video
after understanding the logic of search
and the types of search we will get into
understanding what is linear search
algorithm
the linear search method is a simple
search technique in this type of
searching approach we perform a
sequential search across all objects one
after the other every element is
examined and if there is a match found
then the specific element is returned
otherwise the search will continue until
the data Gathering is complete let us go
through an example for Better Learning
Experience on my screen we have the
following elements 50 10 20 30 70 40 90
60 as randomly distributed elements let
us imagine that our Target element is
70.
we found that our Target element was 70
using linear search strategy so how does
it work in the next segment we will look
into the working terms of linear search
algorithm the simplest method of
searching the data collection is the
linear search starting from the
beginning of the data set each element
is examined until no match is found the
linear search is completed after the
item has located
in the first stage We compare the first
element that is 50. to the search
element that is 70. we will go on to the
next element because 50 and 70 are not
matched
we will compare the second element which
is 10 to the search element that is 70
in the next step
and once more there is no match found
then we have the element 30 as the next
comparison and 70 and 30 are not matched
we have the next element that is 20 in
the fourth phase and there is no match
when we compare 20 with 70. moving on to
the following stage we have the data
element 70 and after comparing 70 with
the search element there is a match
we will now have the searching and
display index as 4 and this index
contains the searched element
we now comprehend the pseudo code of the
linear search algorithm after learning
the working terminology of linear search
algorithm
first we have a function called linear
search which has two variables in its
parameters the arrays name which is an
array and the search variable which is
the value then using a for Loop we must
search for our Target variable by
analyzing all the data elements in the
data set with the condition that is the
search item is identical to any such
value we must return its index value
now we must stop searching once the
searched value has been discovered then
we will close our if and for loop as
well as the linear search function
we will now look into the complexity of
linear search algorithm after
comprehending the pseudo code
the complexity of linear search
algorithm is divided into three
categories the best case which is the
Big O of 1 the average case which is the
Big O of capital n and the worst case
scenario which is same as the average
case which is the Big O of n
here n is the number of data items to be
sorted let us look into how all these
complexities of linear search algorithm
play out in detail
first we have the best case which is Big
O of n as a result the best case
scenario happens when the search element
is found in the data sets first block
as a result the search takes a constant
amount of time
here is an example of an array with 50
10 40 20 30 as the elements now our
search element is 50 which is located in
the first location of the array then
there's the typical case of linear
search algorithm which has Big O often
and occurs when the search element is in
the middle of the data set or any point
of the data set with the array
containing the same search Element 50 we
can easily see that The Element 50 is
present in the center of the array at
the location number 2. finally we have
the worst case which is Big O of n which
is same as that of the average case of
the linear such algorithm and happens
when the search element is in the last
block of the data set as a result of the
number of searches required as
proportional to the number of elements
as demonstrated in this example the
search Element 50 is found in the last
block of the array index which is 4.
in the next segment we will look into
some readable instances of linear social
algorithms according to the first
application of the linear search
algorithm linear search is particularly
efficient when it comes to discovering a
particular string next we will look into
the second application of linear search
algorithm
when a data set has only few elements
linear search is the simplest to
implement the final real world
application of the linear search
algorithm is with the help of telephone
directory you may find out the name of a
person
with the phone number one two three
this can be implemented easily using
linear search algorithm now let us have
a look at the linear search algorithm
working in Practical demonstration so on
my screen we have an example for linear
search algorithm we have included three
libraries standard input output standard
library and console input output Library
then we have entered the main function
where we have declared an array with
maximum size of 50 elements a counter
variable I a variable named Target where
we would store our search element and
finally num variable where the number of
elements in the array is recorded then
we have a printf function to ask the
user how many items are there in the
array and then we use a scanf function
to allow input from the keyboard so we
have added percentage D format specifier
to the scanf function which is used for
numeric values and num variable then
using a for Loop we will try to print
all the items in the array starting with
0 and ending with num variable which is
the last element then we will enter our
search element which we want to find
among all the elements of the array and
as previously said we'll store the found
element in the Target variable following
that we will use the for Loop to examine
all the elements in the array then we
use the if statement to check for the
element is identical to our searched
element or not
if the element is found we exit the
follow and we will break the keyword
and if the target values location is
less than the number of elements in the
array then we will return the location
otherwise if the value location is
greater than the number of elements in
the array then the search will be
unsuccessful and we won't be able to
find the search element now we will
compile this code and see the output
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled now it is asking
for the number of elements in the array
let me give us five elements now let us
enter the elements into the array let us
enter some random elements
now we have entered the five elements
let me provide the searched element as
2.
now we have found the target element to
be found in the location 2. that is 0 1
and 2 yeah 2 is located in the second
index location and with that we have
reached to the end of day one so far we
have learned the data structures on day
two of software development learning we
will reveal the next stage where you get
to master the algorithms thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to stay tuned for more from Simply
learned
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here